tournoi d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes-rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut Fatou j'espère
que tu vas bien que tu as passé hier une
belle soirée après nous a quitté
et salut à toi bonjour à tous tout à
fait j'espère que toi aussi une très
agréable soirée évidemment tu sais qu'il
y a alors attends
alors bonjour à tous voilà je viens
d'ouvrir les chats je vais voir tout ça
et on est prêt Fatou pour le début de
cette dernière ronde du norwechesse avec
encore une fois de très très gros choc
toujours accessoire là
des belles parties en perspective
que j'avais ouvert et qui était qui
était voilà ça y est on est bon pour moi
je suis bon ce côté là et Fatou alors
nous avons 5 parties aujourd'hui très
très chaudes avec un pour commencer
Magnus Carson avec les Blancs qui va
affronter l'ancien champion du monde de
partir rapide
âgé de seulement je crois maintenant 18
ans
nous dire Berk à nos autorieux
pardon
ça va aller ouais ouais comme tu dis
donc les deux joueurs qui font pas un
énorme tournoi jusque là
mais bon je pense qu'ils ont envie de de
finir le tournoi en beauté et de gagner
cette dernière partie donc à savoir que
la dernière fois qu'ils sont affrontés
c'était au tata style et Magnus avait
perdu avec les blanc S
on va voir s'il y a pouvoir prendre sa
revanche ici
vu le début de tournoi aucune partie
gagnée c'est peut-être pas le moment
idéal pour prendre sa revanche mais
Abdou cette robe qui est aussi en galère
dans le tournoi donc pourquoi pas une
première victoire de Magnus qui sait
ouais donc là c'est une défense russe
qui a été joué ou pétrole il y a
plusieurs noms pour cette défense et
c'est une défense qui est extrêmement
solide avec les Noirs donc on va voir si
Magnus a envie d'essayer de de d'avoir
un avantage alors c'est que des trois
c'est pas la vente la plus Sharpe ça
c'est clair et souvent des trois
cavaliers 4 et en fait et ben on a une
Française d'échange
donc espérons qu'on n'est pas cette
ouverture enfin tout parce que je crois
que ça risque de terminer vite si c'est
comme ça Magnus il a souvent
que Nakaya il y a trois jours non
[Musique]
mais je sais que tu as tu as une ligne
que je veux beaucoup dernièrement
c'était Fatou bouger le cavalier
ailleurs quand F3 mais ici aller en
Détroit c'est un coup qu'il a beaucoup
joué ma douche pour que je cavalier F4
et je veux des quatre et taper sur le
pion des 5 un truc comme ça et c'est pas
une blague et donc je sais plus comment
je crois que c'est le dessin qui fait un
truc comme ça et plus tard taper sur le
pion sur le pion
mais bon il ajoute ça plusieurs fois
notamment contre Richard rapport il
avait fait une belle partie belle
victoire comme ça et je pense que
maintenant et ben tout le monde
attendait trois vu qu'il n'avait
plusieurs fois d'affilée et maintenant
il change et il a joué la pollution que
j'attendais Fatou donc c'est une
Française d'échange c'est pareil c'est
comme si on avait joué pour que vous
sachiez c'est comme si on avait joué ça
ça
et ça donc c'est l'ouverture qui est
extrêmement peu ambitieuse pour pour les
deux joueurs donc
à moins que ma muse est une idée
derrière je pense que cette partie Fatou
elle va être très très très rapide
[Musique]
je crois qu'on j'ai pas bien pronostiqué
je te laisse changer Fatou parce que moi
j'ai pas encore pronostiqué donc
c'est pas juste je sais que je fais rien
faire
on les frappe après donc bonjour à tous
à tous ceux qui sont sur le chat bonjour
à Cécile bonjour à wish que Kabu et
bonjour à Adèle bien sûr donc bienvenue
à tous et bienvenue aussi à ceux qui
sont qui sont sur sur Youtube et en tout
cas n'hésitez pas si si vous voulez nous
écrire si vous voulez nous dire bonjour
Si vous voulez à nous poser des
questions ou quoi que ce soit on sera là
pour vous répondre surtout pas tout
envoyer des gentils
cordiaux s'il vous plaît
alors cette ligne avec Dame 2 cavale
j'ai 5 je l'ai vu enfin tout je l'ai vu
en Top 12 quand j'avais joué en Top 12
et ben j'avais un à une ronde très
importante j'avais un de mes joueurs qui
avait joué ça il avait eu les Noirs
contre un joueur qui joue le Top 16
encore aujourd'hui un jour belge
ce que ça va bien terminé pour lui et
ben non non
tu as l'impression alors qu'un jour à
2400 un mètre international qui avait
les blancs contre un jour un chez nous à
2250 par là et on est assez content de
voir que la version française des
changes parce que nous ben avec les
noirs on est quand même moins fort sur
le papier mais
qu'avec G5 et en pratique c'était pas si
simple du tout pour les noirs et il
avait très mal répondu et il avait une
position mauvaise il avait perdu la
partie
alors pour te dire la vérité Fatou je ne
sais pas du tout
comment ça doit se jouer cette position
puis on prend imaginer que ce pion sera
à rire et plus tard et que 5 jours
difficiles à pousser
de mettre en place
et essayer de faire cavaler
E5 derrière ça peut être quelque chose
d'assez thématique mais je ne connais
pas assez la position enfin tout on va
voir un peu comment comment les choses
que je voudrais apprendre où est-ce
qu'il joue puis on prend c'est en tout
cas c'est une idée assez intéressante
salut licorne salut
boys boyache chacun et Obi-Wan tu peux
nous raconter comment se passe à
sélection de Paul championnat de France
individuel ou Fatou
[Musique]
il y a des joueurs qui sont qualifiés
par le vélo ça c'est clair
donc je sais pas quelles sont les
critères exactement mais il y a quand
même pas mal de gens qui sont qualifiés
par le vélo
donc disons plein de qualifications
différentes alors il y a quelque chose
le gagnant de junior du frangin junior
le meilleur et l'eau de moins de 20 ans
il y a ceux qui ont participé à la
précédente édition
qui se requalifie plus les le meilleur
du deuxième
du deuxième tournoi au championnat de
France oui on a l'accession
le tournoi access
qualifié
le règlement pour voir en détail qui
peut se qualifier
c'est difficile comme question ouais
alors du coup je sais plus ouais je ne
sais pas si s'il y a un ou deux qualifié
par l'accession donc c'est un tournoi
qui se joue en même temps que le
championnat de France ou les premiers ou
deux premiers ce qualifie pour pour
jouer le championnat de France
individuel l'année prochaine il y a des
qualgés par hello il y a aussi les
qualifiés ceux qui sont maintenus ce qui
sont arrivés
je sais plus alors je connais pas
peut-être ceux qui ont fait je passe au
hasard quart de finale ou plus les
meilleurs de l'édition précédente qui
peuvent rejouer un truc
c'est intéressant comme question
à comprendre et voir clair salut RK
Fatou va un peu ce qui se fâche chez les
autres on a so Wesley qui est blanc
contre goûter d'une
l'incroyable d'un incroyable récital
contre un tarif c'était monstrueuse qui
nous a fait hier courage
7 ok donc c'est une position très solide
qui est 6 et on opte pour un pion isolé
avec les noirs
et ce pion c'est 5 qui va plus tard être
être mangé donc c'est une position qui
me fait beaucoup penser hier enfin Fatou
a une position qu'on a vu hier chez
entre
entre Magnus et mammedia Rohff un peu le
même genre tu viens ils avaient changé
les fous une dame tu es venue ici on a
réussi à jeter quatre rapidement
c'est ça je peux le pousser sinon je
peux expliquer aussi un petit peu un
petit peu comment jouer comment
construire isoler
ça par cœur qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre
un pion isolé et souffle alors bah
contre un pion isolé bien sûr et on va
commencer par le bloquer donc là on a un
E3 un cavalier en F3 on va essayer de
bloquer ce pion isolé essayer d'échanger
les pièces autant que possible
et après mettre les pièces en attaque
sur ce pion et en défense les noirs
doivent j'ai hyper actifs donc soit on
va réussir en fait un jour à pousser des
quatre pour échanger le pion ce serait
parfait mais si jamais je n'arrive pas à
pousser le pion et à me changer et bien
je dois essayer de jouer hyperactif donc
attaquer le roi par exemple vous la
mettez tour en jeu et essayer vraiment
de faire quelque chose mais de manière
générale éviter les échanges donc là par
exemple Dame des deux
peut être possible mais pas sûr que ce
soit un coup aussi fort parce qu'après
un échange comme ça moi je pense que je
vais manger ici et préparer des quatre
et je pense
[Musique]
je serai pas moins bien mais je ferai
pas non plus mais tu vois alors que les
Blancs quand même peuvent essayer de
pousser un petit peu alors dans cette
partie si vous voulez on peut on peut
vous montrer un petit peu les
classements en cours regardez on va un
peu la différence ici on voit que
pendant je me suis trompé ça c'est
apparemment qu'on va vous montrer mais
on voit que gokuch ici et ben il a 13
points et je vous rappelle que les
systèmes de points en cas de victoire on
gagne trois points enfin en cas de
victoire en classique sur une partie
lente on gagne trois points
en cas de match nul c'est un point
chacun et après on aura une Armageddon
d'un demi points pour le gagnant un
point de bonus donc ici carwana qui a 16
points joue contre Nakamura
s'il n'a qu'à par exemple venait à
battre Fabiano en partie classique il
gagnerait 3 points et donc il passerait
devant karwana et Chypre la première
place
et ensuite joue contre sceau il a 11,5
il passe devant et en plus même regardez
si par exemple
kerwana va Nakamura en partie classique
mais il y a plein de gens qui peuvent
arriver le deuxième même si par exemple
ma caméra fait nul comme Caravana mais
perd la magadon il aura 14 et demi donc
là un joueur comme gokush comme Anish
comme so peuvent tous rattraper ma
caméra vous voyez donc franchement
c'est encore un certain tout ça et c'est
vrai que tous les joueurs enfin en tout
cas les cinq premiers je voulais
vraiment des parties importantes pour le
podium et pour bien terminer donc je
vais revenir sur la partie ici de de
Google chez SOS et donc je pense tu es
quand même pas mal d'enjeux après aussi
des joueurs qui veulent peut-être des
fois à faire match nul et assurer de
bonnes
joueurs qui vont ainsi que de tout faire
pour gagner pour être le mieux placé
possible quitte à perdre et à finir un
peu moins bien et avoir beaucoup de
notes bien sûr
mais
sauf salut c'est le bleu sauf c'est pas
trop son genre de Caroline façon ma
général un genre extrêmement solide
moi je vois bien une je vois bien une
nul ici pas de joueurs c'est un petit
peu
oui mais même c'est pas le joueur qui va
qui va faire en ligne il va il peut
jouer pour gagner ça c'est pas un
problème mais il va pas il va pas non
plus moi je vois pas je le vois pas
prendre tous les risques ici je vois pas
alors ma camera ça c'est la partie très
très importante Fatou
d'ailleurs j'aurais bien aimé la mettre
sur un tableau 1 celle là partie pour le
titre parce que c'était vrai que
si Nakamura venait à battre karwana en
particulier classique il serait premier
ça jurait le nord-ouest 2023 par contre
si ils font nuls il y aura un magasin
mais si c'est nul peu importe
du norwatchesse 2023 donc à dire aussi
que la dernière fois que les gens sont
joués
evanakamura l'avant porté je crois que
c'était avec les Blancs et c'était aux
candidat aux candidat l'année dernière
sur quatre
de l'espagnol avec un sacrifice en F2
vraiment très très théorique Fatou sans
regarder la notation est-ce que tu peux
me dire quelle ouverture c'est moi je
crois que je sais
mais je suis pas sûr à 100% mais je
pense que je sais je pense que c'est
est-ce que tu saurais me dire Fatou
pas très forte pour reconnaître les
ouvertures
je crois
enfin tout je crois que cette position
c'est une italienne avec cavalier 5
et il y a eu tu sais le fameux cavalier
5 avec le fameux D5 j'en prends des 5
cavaliers à 5 fou échec C6 tu vois ce
que veut dire
et je pense que c'est ça en tout cas on
a influencé son incavalion A5 il a pu en
Détroit bizarre ça ressemble beaucoup à
une tructure comme ça salut voilà on
voit que tout fille il a appris à jouer
l'ouverture avec les structures de pions
qui est important
il faut le reconnaître
je vais vérifier alors je suis pas mal
déjà
allez donc là cavalier Fatou je suis à
un coup de gagner je pense
salut Roga sur Youtube salut Steph de
Nice et salutations à ta collègue salut
à toi rouga est-ce que tu es de Nice toi
aussi est-ce qu'on se connaît
H6 cavalier F3 E4 cavalue 5
fou c'est 5
F4
dame de 4 je crois que c'est cette
partie on a vu cette position qui est
extrêmement bizarre les noirs sont hyper
bien développés et les Blancs n'ont rien
en sortie mais j'ai imprime plus avec
les Blancs et ça
c'était vraiment des des ouvertures
enfin des lignes que tu apprends
vraiment avec
avec l'ordinateur quoi avec l'ordinateur
et si tu travailles ça avec l'ordinateur
en fait tu peux le jouer par contre si
tu connais pas enfin l'ordinateur c'est
injouable pour les blancs parce que tu
as surtout qu'une pièce c'est à jouer F4
et tout est bizarre quoi tout est
bizarre donc donc voilà voilà donc ça
c'était la partie qu'on avait vu
c'était
vent de Forest Carsen
et donc là il y a eu trois cavaler les 5
donc il y a 5
le cavalier
les cavaliers F4 on mange ici donc un
peu plus pour les blancs j'ai une
structure difficile paire de fou pour
les Noirs et des cases blanches donc
c'est une position qui est assez 2020 ou
je suis un génie même l'année j'avais
même l'année tu vois c'était un petit
peu à vue de à vue de
enfin si un truc j'aurais dit tabastien
parce que un tournoi ou les deux joueurs
se rencontrent
le tentative c'est sûr
c'est un seul tournoi dans lequel ils
peuvent vraiment rencontrer le Magnus
donc ouais bref donc tout
salut Arnaud bienvenue à tous bien sûr
qu'on se connaît regarde alors bien sûr
regard je ne vois pas qui tu es mais en
tout cas ça fait plaisir que tu sois là
merci à toi un petit message ah bah
c'est dur un dernier pseudo mais
voilà bon retour pression sur le 5 il va
y avoir sur mon fou B2 et cavalier A4 ça
me paraît assez logique d'ailleurs si
jamais les blancs arrivent à jouer à un
plan du style fou B2 cavalez bouger D4
peut-être que je peux réussir à changer
les pions et avoir un plan net de plus
puis on dès qu'il pourra plus tard
avancer mais généralement ça c'est un
petit peu en rêve ça n'arrive pas
les Noirs vont essayer d'empêcher tout
ça
donc
voilà bon je ne connais pas du tout la
position mais ça c'est concret hein ça
c'est concret et la caméra qui joue un
peu je pense sur le fait de surprise
très très très
comment dire très Peugeot alors vous
voyez que cette Italienne avec cavalier
5 chez les débutants c'est hyper courant
c'est un truc que tu vas avoir une
partie sur deux Fatou mais c'est pas
terrible
au niveau tu peux la jouer que si
vraiment tu as une idée pour la jouer
sinon tu ne la joue pas parce que ça
répétait pour être pour être vraiment
très bien pour les Noirs à cause du
scooter on a montré l'avantage de
développement
et
c'est bien préparé chez NACA ouais bon
c'est le début hein
s'il a une idée s'il a une ouais mais là
c'est tout ça c'est connu en fait enfin
même moi en fait j'aurais pu réciter
quoi tu vois c'est assez connu
le fou ici la tour j'en sais rien mais
je veux dire que ça préparation si c'en
est une vraiment à dire profonde je
pense qu'elle va être encore plus loin
que ça quoi
mais après la question c'est juste qu'à
ou et est-ce que vraiment ça peut mettre
Fabiano en difficulté ça c'est
c'est la question en tout cas c'est cool
c'est une partie et Nakamura quand même
il était dans l'ouverture donc à voir
s'il a rien de la pression et hier on
l'a vu d'ailleurs dans l'interview de
carbonara qui disait on l'a demandé si
demain qu'est-ce qui est passé de sa
partie contre quand on a qu'à moi le
fait de devoir faire nul pour gagner un
tournoi etc avec les noirs et il disait
il avait dit que non mais écoutez on va
voir je prends le gain moi je dois faire
nul
si je fais nul ça veut dire que je
mérite de gagner une tournoi etc par
contre si jamais je perds je méritais
pas avec une bête puisque moi c'est un
peu comme ça qui pensait en tout cas
Karuna mais il disait qu'il avait quand
même beaucoup d'expérience qui avait
beaucoup fait de partie avec des enjeux
similaires et que bon ben on allait voir
ce qui se passe
donc voilà en tout cas une partie
intéressante j'espère que elle va elle
va elle va se jouer il y aura pas mal de
Fight ce que j'espère
la théorie de cette ligne est très
ancienne mais à une connaissance
depuis 10 ans avec fou des trois car il
y a 5 avril F3 fous des 6 qui n'était
pas joué auparavant ah ça marche je ne
t'ai pas au courant de ça si elle le
merci pour tes
tes lumières
wesh les conseils type de ligne dans son
cours classical et à jouer ça on regarde
ok je sais pas mais oui bon ça c'est un
truc que tu as au niveau que je joue une
fois tu joues une fois et après tu le
veux plus parce que comme c'est
considéré comme étant pas terrible
terrible si tu le fais une fois pour la
surprise à haut niveau après moins tu es
fort plus tu peux le jouer en fait mais
à haut niveau des joueurs au niveau
théorique sont tellement débrutes et ça
c'est tellement travaillé que ça devient
difficile c'est vrai
donc donc ok intéressant en tout cas
Fatou tout ça
est-ce que vous allez voir Thierry Mamed
et après on ira avoir on ira finir avec
tari contre irou hop
alors Fatou cette ouverture
c'est quoi cette ouverture
il faut encore deviner
mais j'ai peur de devenir
j'ai peur de Dieu j'ai peur
qu'elle allait prendre quelque chose à
mettre trois fois
espagnol
j'en sais rien du tout ou je suis là
j'avais dit tout ça Fatou hein je
l'avais dit dans ma tête je sais pas si
tu m'as entendu mais je l'avais dit
bien sûr la seule erreur que j'ai fait
dans ma tête à savoir que j'ai fait dans
ma tête c'était que je pensais qu'ici il
allait faire
et lors du coup j'avais dit ça mais j'ai
pas vu avec cavaler prendre des cartes
et bon ça revient éventuellement
évidemment au même Fatou
alors attends j'ai perdu le direct de la
partie
donc j'ai besoin que j'aime bien pour la
plante à tout moi j'aime bien quand le
centre il est ouvert comme ça et que je
peux
dame G3 à faire F4 et que j'ai et que je
suis libre un petit peu au centre et que
je peux avancer des pions j'aime
beaucoup ces positions
ouais on a l'espace
noir des noirs pour attaquer son G7
tu parles de l'autre position je pense
de la carte
non je sais pas que tu parles
[Musique]
parce que je vois pas
les dessins
[Musique]
je sais pas les coeurs moi mon plan ce
serait plutôt de jouer alors il y a des
dessins qui peut arriver un jour c'est
un coup typique peut-être pas pour
l'instant
mais je pense que l'idée c'est un moment
donné je sois cases noires avec ce fou
moi j'aurais F4
F4 la MG3 je pousserai des pions
j'enverrai tout
c'est ce que j'essaierai de jouer en
tout cas je sais pas ce que tu en penses
mais
on profite en général quand on a quand
on a le centre quand on a un avantage
d'espace
si on nous le donne autant le prendre
après c'est que souvent F4 en fait je
sais que des noirs très souvent dans ce
type de position et ben
il va jouer ici soit du style genre T6
et sur un coup comme F4 les Noirs aiment
bien jouer alors je vais imaginer bon
Caval et B4 juste pour imaginer la
situation des fois on aime enfin les
Noirs aiment bien jouer F5 sur F4
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que ça va ouvrir un casque blanche pour
ce foulard et une fois que tu bloques le
pion F4 et ben les blancs sont pas
forcément contents d'avoir
ouvert ces cases noires
ça peut être puni par F5 des fois donc
là il faut voir vraiment l'enjeu est-ce
que je peux jouer E5
pour te dire toi aussi tu t'es bloqué
parce que je mange en me disant tiens
plus tard je vais virer ton fou parce
que c'est vrai qu'en juin F5 jusqu'à
m'ouvrir la case enfin la diagonale
blanche mais ça c'est assez thématique
dans ces positions donc voilà il y a eu
cavaliers
en tout cas il faut des fentes
il y a un coup qui me dérange avec le
noir et là je comprends un peu l'idée
moi je pense qu'il faut bouger la dame
je pense ça va être le coup
parce que j'ai l'impression je me trompe
peut-être enfin tu vois mais je vais
essayer on va essayer je rappelle que
nous on n'a pas de base de données on a
pas l'ordinateur on joue avec notre tête
ce qui est pas facile pour Fatou
j'aime beaucoup l'attaquer Fatou alors
c'est que le début et en fait du coup
sur cavaler je vais 4
l'idée c'est que je pense que si jamais
on joue fou à 4 est-ce que je peux jouer
ici des cinq voilà c'est mon idée j'ai
mon cavalier qui défend en fait des cinq
et je me dis que si je fais à 3
pour virer ce cavalier et essayer de
enlever le défenseur de la pièce en D5
et ben j'étais 4
fait une fourchette je me dis que ça
peut être
un moyen de de casser le centre avec les
avec les avec les Noirs sachant qu'à
trois n'est pas un coup et une fois
qu'on échange bah écoute la structure
serait symétrique et les Noirs
pourraient être pour être réalisé
c'est pour ça que dame 2 Adam D2 avec
les jouets d'accord bon Dame des deux
encore donc encore mieux ils vont
empêcher des cinq peut-être mais l'idée
de faire dame 2 pour moi ce que je
pensais c'est qu'en fait
sur des 5 il y a plus de fourchette
donc sur des cinq peut-être que j'avais
quand même à 3
mais maintenant il faut calculer à 3 et
4 peut-être que ça marche j'en sais rien
tu vois ça reste peut-être
plus hein
comme tu l'as dit aussi à tout moment
je sais pas trop il va donc en tout cas
je pense que voilà bouger la dame ça
pour moi c'était un coup logique mais
alors où et c'est vrai que Tam des deux
me surprend enfin tout parce qu'on le
fou sur plus
il va sortir
avec du bleu trois fou B2 ou alors
encore bouger la dame et on n'aime pas
trop jouer
dix fois la même pièce dans l'ouverture
mais pourquoi pas alors l'idée
vraiment à tout prix
et cette garder une carte pour le fou je
sais pas j'essaie d'avoir des d'avoir un
peu
de comprendre le sens de ce coup
sur B3 F6 qui peut me poser problème
aussi que tu as dès que tu joues B3
imaginons alors je joue un coup juste
pour passer mon tour d'accord
si je joue bet3 et aussi du foie F6
comme tu l'as proposé et maintenant sur
un comme tout bébé j'ai encore une fois
des cinq parce que il y a un vis-à-vis
il y a un clouage et que ton cavalier
peut pas manger en dessin donc tu vois
ce que je m'en fous
ce que je m'en fous dans le sens comme
peut-être que je joue jusqu'à Valais
ok bon c'est intéressant de voir comment
ils vont placer leur pièce c'est comment
il joue parce que c'est une position qui
est inconnue
en tout cas pour moi
et je trouve que c'est assez facile à
jouer pour le blanc c'est pour ça c'est
plus ouvert et je pense que si jamais
ma mère je joue pas précis et bien il
peut se retrouver dans une belle
poubelle par exemple là si je vais en
couple assis je fais à 3 Cavalier rouge
qui est D5 et ça commence à être pas mal
pour le blanc donc
apparemment je connais même très bien
avec Kuga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je peux avoir des indices
des indices
et là je peux deviner c'est compliqué là
qui RS déjà en son temps donc peut-être
c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà de
l'expérience quelqu'un qui
est d'une génération peut-être que la
mienne
vous parlez de caresse mais je sais pas
il m'en faut plus quelqu'un pour
m'expliquer les enjeux de cette position
alors Adrien chaudron sur Youtube bien
sûr Adrien bah on a essayé de faire tout
à l'heure c'est compliqué les Noirs
veulent jouer pardon pour dessiner le
centre ça ça va être l'idée des Noirs
les Blancs font tout pour essayer
d'empêcher des cinq tu vois Dame des
deux a été joué je bloque mon fou mais
je veux vraiment empêcher des zinc
et l'enjeu c'est ça c'est c'est joué
pour le centre quoi et les blancs
prennent le pari que les Noirs vont pas
le faire mais les Noirs ils pensent que
si et donc là avoir si je peux jouer
ah ça y est ça y est bon c'est très
facile regarde
extrêmement facile salut à toi je crois
depuis enfin depuis carrosse même si je
ne me trompe pas
elle est l'ouverture e4k6 E5 cavalier G8
donc si Laurent Freyssinet avait été là
on aurait pu en plus me moquer enfin se
moquer de lui parce que Laurent
Freyssinet a perdu contre manuscrite
avec cette position avec les Blancs
Magnus qu'il a trop le complet en jean
ça et et Laurent qui a refusé la nul
parce qu'il s'est dit non c'est quand
même pas acceptable comme cette
couverture etc il a dit non je vais
refusais la nul il a perdu quelques
coups après et bon j'aurais bien
accepter la nul bref et donc je sais qui
tu es ruga je sais qui tu es des joueurs
qui jouent cette ouverture il n'a pas
beaucoup pas beaucoup dans le monde des
échecs Bricard ça aurait pu d'ailleurs
il a sûrement déjà joué un bain car
c'est c'est un joueur qui adore aussi ce
type de
figure-toi que je l'ai joué aussi à
Freyssinet non sérieux
et ben écoute ce sera répété la
prochaine fois que je serai avec
freyciné qu'on reparlera de cette
ouverture parce qu'à chaque fois on aime
bien ça avait se moquer des uns et des
autres quand on est en string c'est pas
tout
oui et du coup c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que je lui répète
à quelle occasion tu l'as joué
il faut le jouer quoi moi je l'ai joué
une fois j'ai de la chance de le jeu en
top en Top 12 un Top 16 au top 12 il y a
quelques années et bon comme vous
imaginez bien
Ricard il joue il a joué tous les trucs
possibles et imaginables et tous les
trucs un peu tordus d'ailleurs
[Musique]
quand même c'est vrai
tu commences avec trois temps de moins
mais tu as des cases pas des cases donc
C6 voilà je voulais pas par un média
Rohff
à tout prix
très très sûrement un regard
la capsule G5 ouais ouais ouais ouais
moi je l'avais joué Ricard pour ma
première norme de MI et je devais faire
nul contre lui et
gagner en 2002 le lendemain c'était en
National et j'ai juste contrôlé que les
blancs et il m'a joué une une ouverture
comment ça s'appelle
[Musique]
et j'étais hors prépa au premier coup et
premier coup hors théorie enfin je fais
cavaler 3 je savais que c'était le coup
mais j'avais jamais vu ça de ma vie
j'avais 2300 et quelques kilos et donc
j'ai joué comme ça et puis bah j'ai fait
un truc normal et j'ai envoyé 4 bref et
j'ai gagné très rapidement il m'a donné
une pièce en un coup mais il a mis une
pièce en prise donc je l'ai mangé tout
simple il abandonné j'ai de la chance
mais
comme ça ma première après on s'était
rejoué quelques années après en un an
encore j'avais les Noirs cette fois-ci
mais des gens un truc bizarre
et et j'avais une position difficile et
j'avais réussi à faire un peu en plus
mais il avait la part de vous c'était
vraiment très complexe et il m'a proposé
nul mais bon bon j'avais un peu en plus
c'est moi et j'ai refusé j'ai perdu
quelques cours après mince un très bon
regard grand maître bien sûr
d'ailleurs il a écrit un livre je pense
sur la stratégie Fatou
et c'est un il est très très bon
stratégie
non mais je
l'ai pratiquement et après je le dis pas
mais je pense que tu es pas le seul ici
à avoir plein de livres d'échecs mais
j'ai une bibliothèque de bouquins
d'échec mais j'en ai jamais ouvert un
j'en ai lu quand même mais ouais tu fais
croire aux gens en fait regarde
il faut dire ça pour être fort et toi tu
le mets toi le bouquin tu l'as même pas
lu même pas ouvert typique non mais j'en
ai lu qu'un des bouquins mais mais
rarement en entier genre j'ai la
collection des des
vrais ski et je l'ai menti sauf un que
je t'avais dit que je l'avais perdu dans
l'avion je l'ai oublié dans l'avion
voilà c'était secret of opening préparer
dans l'avion dégoûté
et mais je vais tous lu à peu près à la
moitié à chaque fois après bon je prends
notre livre mais bon je l'ai je l'ai je
regarde pas mal quand même
dans les transports dès que j'en
transporte savoir que je bouffe des
bouquins d'échec
donc à 5 Fatou quelle a été à 5
quelle va être libre à 5
tu tiens le cavalier mais par contre
cavalier noir il a plus beaucoup de
cases
assise bon il l'avait déjà mais
là tu l'as tu peux retourner avec
plusieurs manières de prendre déjà ça
peut être plus intéressant
donc tu te libères une petite cage je
pense que c'est ça le oui l'idée
prendre de la tour parce que sinon c'est
une structure un peu dégueulasse et le
Caval qui va revenir ici pour GTA je
pense
je pense que c'est son idée donc pendant
que Aniche va perdre du temps pour pour
sortir cette pièce et ben les Noirs vont
presque cavaler pour jeter 5 je pense
clairement ça l'idée
après en pratique c'est pas encore
simple
à trois c'est pas du tout obligatoire
et plein de fois même je peux même
sacrifier le pion en fait je pense pour
que je ça ça a fou F5 rapidement
attaquer ces deux je pense qu'il y a des
moments où tu ou des fois tu peux donner
pour l'activité aussi ça c'est pas
c'est pas déconnant tu en fait les les
Noirs le jour où ils arrivent à jouer
des seins qui vont quand même avoir
l'avance de développement du au fait que
mes pièces marche un peu dessus donc
c'est pas non plus étonnant qu'un jour
plus de 5 à tarifs et puis encore pour
l'activité pour du jeu et jouer type
five 6 x 5 et jouer sur sur ces pions là
quoi ce serait pas un truc si étonnant
que ça
donc voir un peu comment ça se passe
mais bon oui à 3 cavaliers à 6 et
tourner un
ou dame bouge pour ressentir le fou
serait totalement
acceptable en tout cas je pense mais
voilà alors RK je ne suis pas de
carrosse mais je crois que ruga qui est
qui est sur Youtube en fait il y a deux
chats en même temps parce que on avait
déjà de Youtube et de twitch Rega je
crois qu'il est de carrosse c'est pour
ça que mais je connais bien carrosse
parce que je suis allé souvent les
carrosse c'est à côté de Nice c'est de
hauteur de Nice en fait
c'est des hauteurs de Nice et
je connais plusieurs personnes qui
habitent à carrosse
donc donc voilà mais les jaboulets
je ne sais pas ce que c'est je vais me
faire des ennemis sur le chat du coup
lors tu connais carrosse mais
j'aboulé je ne sais pas ce que c'est
et on voit un synchrose qui salue le
chat de
de twitch en passant par Youtube c'est
beau les gens vous allez faire des amis
vous allez vous croiser comme ça ça peut
être sympa par contre je vais pas vous
lire à chaque fois c'est toi salut à
toutes en tout cas et n'hésitez pas à
nous partager
[Musique]
c'est peut-être le meilleur joueur
d'échec du village
il a 2200 à peu près FX et
[Musique]
voilà un très très bon ami à moi aussi
ok Fatou
et on va aller
car voilà qui a blender où on va aller
voir ça rapidement où ça m'a mais mais
très vite on va aller voir on va juste
rapidement voir cette partie qui est
Fatou c'est assez facile à trouver je
pense alors on a deux choix là par
rapport à l'ouverture
mais deux choix qui transpose mais je
vais quand même partir sur l'espagnol
c'est un espagnol ou une Sicilienne avec
Google
donc Fatou
donc va rendre de Moscou avec ou
espagnol et voilà
bien évidemment en fait c'est deux
lignes qui transposent voilà tous les
trois et on mange trop de tombe dans une
sorte d'espagnol et très souvent on va
voir un cavalier B8 qui va être placé
chez les Noirs plus tard pour venir en
C6 c'est hyper thématique tout ce que
fait notre ami à donc ça c'est hyper
théorique donc
moi je joue cette position en fait
souvent mais en passant par la
Sicilienne moi je joue pas l'espagnol
avec les blancs mais je rentre dans
cette position en passant par les
acidiens
c'est pour ça que je connais voilà qui
avait les B3 fou B1
et les positions qui sont assez
compliquées les Blancs ont l'avantage
on l'avantage ici d'espace mais c'est
une potion qui est assez symétrique
finalement au niveau de la structure
donc souvent c'est assez égal c'est
position
donc H3 x 3 et ici assez commun assez
normal et on va voir un petit peu
comment ça va comment ça va continuer
cette partie ça touche je propose qu'on
aille vite rapidement voir karwana parce
que Oussama il me fait un peu peur sur
sur Youtube en disant que Fabi aurait
blender mais effectivement F5 c'est un
couple la jauge déteste enfin tout on va
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
donc nous on s'est arrêté alors il y
avait eu C5 x 3 et qu'à aller au 4 qui
va mettre la pression ici et là il a pas
défendu le pion
j'imagine qu'il veut se
refaire sur Détroit derrière
tourcien F5 et la chose qui n'aime pas
du tout Fatou
alors déjà
de comprendre pourquoi F5 ça fait un bon
coup
oups ça mal fait mais vous avez compris
ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
à tout à l'heure
je crois qu'elle m'entend pas la
on peut venir sur le chat ou est-ce que
c'est Fatou qui qui bug il y en a un qui
bug
ah
c'est moi ça marche donc complètement
merci les gens merci c'est Fatou qui
m'ignore complètement en fait
tout à l'heure je lui parle elle répond
pas quoi d'accord ok je me rappelle rien
[Musique]
je me rappellerai Fatou qui
alors si on veut être sûr si vous entend
pas mais je pense que que on peut dire
plein de mal d'elle
elle m'a mute pourquoi tu m'as mis
quoi
que elle veut pas nous parler
elle est partie voilà ça y est elle bout
de
alors F5 on va essayer de comprendre
j'ai eu peur pendant parce que c'est que
des fois des fois mon micro en fait et
Ben et ben il s'éteint tout seul donc je
voulais être sûr que mon micro marche
bien
donc c'est pas toi qui bug en fait c'est
pas moi ok j'ai buggé tu m'entends
très bien
je t'ai posé un tas de questions et tu
me répondais jamais j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle a je suis à tout mon
micro marche donc le chat m'a dit qu'on
micro marche bien
c'est pour ça que j'ai déconnecté ok ça
marche donc je disais Fatou est-ce que
tu as la rêve de F5 je j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi est-ce que parce
qu'en plus là Fatou
alors je suis désolé vous n'avez pas
l'avoir je la couper Fatou pendant
quelques secondes sur la caméra c'est
normal si vous ne la voyez plus
vous inquiétez pas
un petit peu de toute façon voilà
organise tous mes écrans
parce qu'en fait
j'ai reçu
un confessionnal
de Hikaru
et après j'ai reçu un deuxième
confusion avec le titre qui dit bon je
te le traduis dis Hikaru s'ennuie et
revenu
voilà Caro il joue de la gare le gagne
tournois et le mec il vient
il vient et il adore
parler aux gens et je pense plus
important pour lui de parler de parler
aux
femmes que
c'est notre porteur sur place
alors du coup est-ce que je peux faire
cavaler princesse
mais j'ai aussi pensé à cavaler G5 pour
exterminer une dame par ici ça peut être
pas mal mais qui avait raison je pense
qu'il y a H6 et ça a pas l'air d'être
génial alors je crois que j'ai pas le
temps de faire B4 donc cavalier
[Musique]
encore
mais bon ça a quand même pas mal je
prends un pion pourquoi est-ce que ce
coup enfin tout est si mauvais
je sais pas à part la prise du pion
je ne sais pas est-ce qu'il est mauvais
parce que c'est il y en avait un bien
meilleur
à jouer ah oui il y avait un meilleur
coup à jouer mais
parfois ils mettent mauvais juste quand
il y a la joue je vais tricher ouais
c'est ça
mais en fait ouais mais bon ça c'est
voilà le plus de pour les blancs
mais dès que je joue qu'elle va les
princesses il revient
plus 0,7 06
ça c'est la jauge qui ne comprend plus
rien ce que les joueurs sont beaucoup
trop forts forts
de plus maintenant
très bizarre Fatou cette histoire
est-ce que c'est
tu me rends la cage des cavaliers quoi
je peux revenir donc ça c'est bizarre on
cherche
mais bon là j'ai des pions plus quand
même attention Naka qui peut clairement
créer quelque chose est-ce que Fatou tu
veux qu'on aille voir les conventionnels
de
parce que cette partie elle est hyper
importante c'est la partie du gain du
tournoi et il a déjà vu deux fois
faire des interviews pendant la partie
donc est-ce que tout le monde veut le
voir
après je sais pas combien de temps ça va
durer
il a tendance à beaucoup parler mais
j'ai aussi caravane qui est venu
aussi car c'est qui est venu et c'est
sous-titré normalement donc
on va aller voir
une question est-ce que tu es l'ancien
maître de canechec Oui Oui Adèle non
oui enfin par Maître tu tu dois pas
entraîneur j'ai entraîné au Club de
Cannes et aussi dans les écoles et tout
ça quoi à Cannes pendant quelques années
pendant presque 5 ans j'ai été
j'ai été entraîneur à Cannes donc oui
oui oui
c'est bien moi le
je suis plus l'entraîneur de Cannes
maintenant je travaille plus à Cannes
j'ai déménagé maintenant j'habite en
Espagne mais c'est bien moi qui qui
était là-bas
et attends j'ai un deuxième
confessionnal de
fou alors attendez un il est encore un
mais il a encore un mais avec des avec
je pense c'est le deuxième je vais
prendre celui-là
F5 je pense pas qu'on va le voir parce
que là il est pas venu
attendre 2 secondes tu m'attends je vais
aller je pense que ton coup c'est de la
merde
s'il se lève sur son temps
alors
F5
alors je vais vous mettre la première
vidéo parce que ok on parle en parlant
par là j'ai envie de voir ce qui se
passe
donc on part sur Naka et on revient dans
un instant
[Musique]
accélérée pour pour qu'on puisse voir la
deuxième
confessionnelle de 10 carreaux donc il
parle de la partie de kokesh
c'est une partie qui est importante pour
le classement général x une partie
assez standard et il pense que Google a
surpriso engendre le C5 qu'il a joué
dans l'ouverture
c'est 5 cette position
en jouant ici du coup c'est 5 voilà et
il dit que il pense enfin il va voir si
ça va essayer d'avoir un petit avantage
dans nos barres dans la partie pour
jouer sinon il pense à faire nul assez
rapidement il part de sa partie derrière
et dit que ça partit à lui et ben c'est
une partie qu'il a joué
enfin la dernière fois qu'il a le cette
partie c'était il y a 14 ans et il parle
cette partie qu'il a juste un États-Unis
etc
donc il parle que il avait gagné la
partie assez rapidement et que c'était
une super idée donc il parle un petit
peu de comment il avait été amené je
souhaite ouverture etc
et
en tout cas il est assez content de la
surprise il sait que les joueurs sont
enfin se joue
tellement de fois que Ben la fin ils ont
ils connaissent tellement qu'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent se permettre ce type
d'ouverture etc
donc à la fin ça c'est marrant ce qu'il
dit il dit que
depuis 10 minutes Clarin de parler à la
caméra et ben il pense que karena a
dadju son coup et à tempo et du coup il
doit avoir 10 minutes de moins à la
pendule sur moi donc c'est assez drôle
et voilà donc ça représente là j'ai fait
un résumé en 30 secondes de ce qu'il a
pu dire et si vous voulez on part sur la
deuxième
interview qu'il a fait il y a quelques
[Musique]
vidéos il y a un petit montage on voit
les petits échecs
[Musique]
je sais que au début il montrait en fait
il fera qu'il a pas trop parler je crois
qu'il a juste montré je crois qu'il a
juste montré la partie en elle-même
de ce qui se passe en ce moment mais il
a pas du tout joué les variantes il me
semble enfin j'ai pas trop regardé je
vais regarder plus
qui a été joué
[Musique]
donc il part de nouveautés où est-ce
qu'il dit que c'est lui qui l'avait le
fouet 3 et qui a pris une fois qu'il l'a
joué ça d'une population
non c'est pas vrai nacaraté n'importe
quoi et
après oui en fait tu as des parties
c'est des nouveautés tu peux dire que ça
n'a jamais été joué après les parties
qui sont des quasi nouveautés ça veut
dire que dans la base ils sont joués par
quasiment personne donc tu peux voilà
mais tu t'appropries pas comme nouveauté
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est un
quasiment une variante qui n'est pas
joué donc voilà après bon ben c'est un
joueur qui aime bien aussi en raconter
donc on va lui laisser
Fatou est-ce qu'on pense sur cette
dernière confession là qui a l'air sympa
confession la suite allez voilà Amina
[Musique]
ok ok bon c'était assez long c'était
assez long et je viens de manger 5
bon pour faire pour faire rapide
il a parlé de de Magnus
Abdou zikmag nue pas terrible et il a
dit que ma venue ça faisait plusieurs
jours qu'il faisait plein plein de Blitz
tous les jours pour essayer de gagner
peut-être de la confiance
et et là il joue pas bien etc il a dit
que Abdou il faisait un enfin que là il
était hyper préparé sur ce que manus
jouait donc pour ce qu'il y aura pas
d'avantage
je crois qu'il a pas parlé d'autres
ouvertures ah oui il a dit que Giri
c'était bizarre mais bon ok et il a pas
parlé du tout de tarif Hiro et dans sa
partie il a dit que il y avait plein de
plans bizarres plein de plans différents
que dans cette position après c'est 5
etc c'est ça que c'était un des coups il
dit que on peut jouer cavalier 4 ou four
à 3 et que sur un coup ou l'autre et
bien il y a beaucoup qui sont très
précis pour les blancs et pour les noirs
et que bon lui il savait ce qu'il
faisait mais que karena est en train
d'essayer de te souvenir de ce qu'il
fallait faire
et il a dit que cawana parlait beaucoup
de temps à réfléchir c'était cool et il
pensait qu'il allait continuer à perdre
beaucoup de temps
il a dit aussi que ce qui est
intéressant donc ça ça peut vous servir
pour ceux qui jouent beaucoup de
tournois
il dit qu'en fait là cette partie elle a
un gros enjeu donc il y a un enjeu bon
financier bon les joueurs très très
belle leur vie mais il y a aussi pour
gagner le tournoi donc prestigieux aussi
et quand tu as une dernière ronde et que
tu joues vraiment pour gagner le tournoi
et ben il dit que
si tu arrives à surprendre l'adversaire
et je vais peut-être tout impôt donc
blitzer un petit peu la partie et ben
c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen de
gagner la partie c'est voilà surprendre
l'adversaire en tout cas c'est ce que
lui il dit c'est ce que lui il fait et
il dit que la dernière partie de ton des
candidats
mis à jour contre Ding et en fait
Nakamura qui qui a glissé toute
l'ouverture et ben il s'est rendu compte
que Ding et avait l'air un peu blasé par
le fait que Ding enfin Ding avait la
place parce que naquage ou tout impôts
et du coup un petit peu bluffé si vous
voulez le fait qu'il était dans sa
préparation pour pour casser un peu le
moral sur l'adversaire alors en fait pas
forcément préparer la ligne mais voilà
et donc c'est important de d'essayer de
surprendre l'adversaire c'est ce qu'il
c'est ce qu'il dit et du coup il est
assez content de sa position il dit
qu'il se sent bien qu'il a envie de
jouer qu'il a envie de gagner
et que il est content de ce qu'il a fait
dans l'ouverture elle sera préparation
et il pense que avec ça peut-être que ça
peut marcher qui peut réussir à battre
car voilà là aussi parler de de des
candidats et c'est vrai que alors je
sais pas quel zélo ils prennent et quand
ça marche mais par rapport au hello
c'est important de garder un gros hello
d'avoir un élo assez haut assez élevé
pour se qualifier au candidat tu sais
que pour le qualification pour les
candidats il y a des places qui se font
par le vélo et là tous les joueurs ils
ont 2780 et elles sont à trois points
hello prêt et du coup ben voilà et vu
que lui il s'en fout un peu justement
dans ce tournoi là on voit qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup de changements parce que
les joueurs
et plus fort joueurs se jouent entre eux
et en fait là il y a quelques banques ça
bouge par-ci par là et le classement
mondial change
va changer après
on a vu que Nakamura est passé numéro 2
mondial après car on a gagné une partie
donc il a pas ce numéro de mondiale là
actuellement ce qu'ils regardent la
maintenance bon un Magnus qui est numéro
1 mais deuxième on a Fabiano Cabana qui
a
2786,5
Firuza 3e 83,8 Nakamura 82,4 digraine 80
ça se joue à rien et bref donc en fait
il disait que pour les candidats c'est
vrai qu'avoir un gros hello c'est
important et ça permet de se qualifier
pour les candidats et il dit que lui il
s'en fout un peu ça regarde pas parce
qu'apparemment lui il aura pas jouer à
cette partie pour être éligible par le
hello donc après je sais pas quels sont
mes règles correctement mais bon voilà
il a envie quand même de bien finir et
ça que si gagne cette partie bah il
passe numéro 2 mondiale donc c'est quand
même quelque chose en plus de tout ça
donc voilà le résumé c'est à peu près ça
après il a fait 5000 audio
il parle très vite donc je peux pas vous
faire un résumé de tout ce qu'il a dit
mais en gros les grosses lignes c'est à
peu près ça donc salut sharkus salut
olicia salut merci Perse
je pense que c'est juste un pion mais
c'est le deuxième oui c'est clair on va
voir un peu ce qui se passe ça les Mick
pour info
C5 car c'est 5 une grosse merde ok ok
parce que nous dit ici ciel bleu c'est
qu'ici à la place de jouer C5
pendant F6 c'est le coup le plus solide
et moi je connais pas du tout
et plus tard éventuellement faire ses 5
donc si ça défend depuis 1,5
et ok parce qu'apparemment la ligne avec
C5 direct et ben c'est très concret au
niveau de l'ordinateur et donc bah
écoutez moi j'y connais rien tout ça
mais l'ordinateur il donne quand même un
bel avantage blanc
donc on va voir un peu en tout cas ce
qui se passe la jauge des fois on peut
la croire des fois non mais
avoir en tout cas je sais pas du tout je
sais pas quoi vous dire
à trouver un coup pour le noir donc il y
avait des quatre par exemple juste pour
voir
ce qui nous dit
en plus il dit
ça fait encore un pion tu me donnes un
trois pions
ça a pas l'air génial ça pour les pour
les Noirs quand même
l'impression que j'ai quand même
des pions de plus quoi
poser bien sûr favorise l'attaque
mais je trouve que les les blancs s'en
sortent quand même pas mal du tout
écoute Fatou j'ai envie de faire
confiance à la jauge j'ai envie de dire
que Nakamura il fait une partie
intéressante et qui est peut-être qui
peut aller chercher karena
concrètement
[Musique]
approuve maintenant
prouve-moi que on entend au
confessionnels
[Musique]
si vous y croyez pas vous êtes beaucoup
plus de difficultés à gagner le mental
est hyper important aux échec et caronel
il y a tellement
il a tellement aucun problème à ce
niveau là tellement confiance en lui il
a l'air en tout cas donc je pense que
un bon tournoi il est content et en fait
c'est vrai que Nakamura en fait par
rapport à il y a quelques temps en fait
tu sais quand tu vois ces joueurs là il
y a une différence entre Nakamura et
d'autres joueurs parce que c'est vrai
que Nakamura et ben il joue quand même
beaucoup moins échecs qu'avant tu vois
il est enfin ok il joue beaucoup en
stream voilà c'est pas du c'est pas
très différent on va pas dire que c'est
pas le même
jeu mais jouer en 3D en 2D je veux des
parties lentes et jouer des petites sur
Internet c'est il y a quand même une
grosse différence c'est ça
et en fait donc des tournois en en
IRL enfin tout va me dire qu'il va pas
direl Fatou
et ben Naka il en joue quasiment plus
c'est vrai et donc là je pense comme ça
comme il joue maintenant peut-être deux
trois ton apparent grand max
et ben il a juste envie de bien jouer
quoi et de faire un bon tournoi alors
que la majorité des joueurs qui sont ici
eux aussi veulent bien sûr bien jouer
faire des montants noirs mais là Naka je
pense que tu vois l'envie en fait la
motivation quand tu joues un ton
apparence par exemple
ben tu as envie de jouer en fait tu vois
tu as envie de le jouer parce que
toujours plus depuis longtemps et que tu
as envie de bien faire alors
enchaînes plein de tournois tout le
temps comme Magnus par exemple et ben
j'ai envie de dire que la motivation le
fait d'avoir vraiment l'envie de jouer
et elle était un peu moins grande chez
les autres parce que Ben les joueurs
jouent tous les jours tu vois encore une
fois là on a vu bon les gens qui sont
ici tu as plein de tournoi tout le temps
tout le temps de partout et ben écoute
je suis joue tous les jours quoi pas
tous les jours mais Google s'il y a pas
un mois où il y a pas de temps quoi par
exemple
Apple Store pareil et après tu vois les
sauts les les guigris tout le temps ils
sont en tournoi
alors que Nakamura il est plus trop en
tournant il a joué les il a joué le
temps des candidats il y a
bon c'était maintenant il y a combien de
temps il y a il y a un an
et avant ça
ça faisait combien de temps qu'il avait
pas joué aux échec je crois que bon il y
a eu le confinement et tout ça je crois
quasiment deux ans je crois donc en
trois ans il a dû faire un voire deux
tournois et
il a envie de chèque simplement
envie ça lui manque tu vois plutôt que
un carbona qui joue tout le temps bien
sûr que tu arrives bien faire mais
ils acceptent aussi plus facilement
qu'il y ait du déchet parce que
ils peuvent pas tous les réussir leur
tournant donc s'ils sont en forme un
mois le mois suivant
s'il faut pas aussi bien c'est plus
acceptable ils vont se dire qu'ils vont
se refaire rapidement alors que Naka lui
non c'est sûr que s'il joue un deux
trois tournoi par an bah il se refait
pas rapidement
mais là ça tu as envie de jouer en fait
tu as envie de jouer que les autres
n'ont pas forcément parce que ils jouent
tout le temps
de faire ces petits streams au
concessionnals parfait pour lui je pense
qu'il est il est aux anges c'est un
format qui qui doit tellement lui
convenir
est-ce qu'on irait pas voir Magnus ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu sa
partie et d'ailleurs on avait tout à
l'heure enfin j'ai un une confession de
Magnus
donc peut-être qu'on peut aller voir
après sa confession une fois qu'on aura
vu sa partie voir un peu ce qui nous a
dit donc c'est pas la confession à
quelle heure elle est arrivée je sais
pas trop
de quoi ça parle si tu veux on pourra
aller découvrir ce que Magnus vu que là
je crois que ça sera sous-titré
alors tout à l'heure on s'est arrêté je
sais plus trop où je t'ai arrêté
vers là donc il y a eu ces trois petits
roc petit rock E5 directement
puis on prend un prend et donc c'est une
finale
où ici les Noirs ont l'air d'avoir une
position quand même extrêmement solide
trop bien cavalier G4 cavalier 12
cavalier C5
pas grand chose en fait
assez égal et je même si Magnus il est
très très fort dans les positions
dans les positions
à dire égale où il peut pousser un peu
et ben on va voir si on arrive à avoir
une position en tout cas Manu ça a l'air
de fou
la structure elle est pas vraiment
symétrique vous voyez là les Blancs ont
trois contre quatre de l'autre côté ces
trois comptes 2 donc c'est pas vraiment
symétrique c'est égal même Agnus aime
beaucoup ses positions égales on va voir
si mamie arrive
à mettre la pression
tu as de la poussée de l'idée de plus
tard je B4 et essayer de faire une sorte
d'attaque de minorité une possibilité
de tenir un cadre
il faut le défendre enfin tout très bien
attention
donc bon avoir est-ce qu'on va voir on
va aller voir ça tout là la confession
de Magnus alors je sais pas s'ils
étaient quelque chose qui était avant la
partie pendant la partie je sais pas du
tout
en même temps que la caméra en fait
ok donc on va voir
parce que
[Musique]
ok Fatou alors il nous a dit tout
simplement que
j'ai pas bien compris en fait
il avait la mort de rire mais
il a juste dit que c'est cool d'arriver
à la dernière partie il a dit qu'il
avait checké un peu ce que je jouais
enfin
je sais pas
je revois exactement
je crois et que
[Musique]
et quoi déjà la fin il se n'est plus de
ce qu'il avait joué donc je je
j'ai l'impression qu'il avait check un
truc qui avait déjà oublié ce qu'il
fallait jouer un truc comme ça
mais
[Musique]
se termine
un et que des nulle derrière par contre
il a gagné tous ses armags
ce serait symétrique quelque part
une victoire
ouais bah il faut il faut mais bon il
accueille une position qu'il aime bien
tu vois il a une potion qui est pas
vraiment symétrique il a la part de fou
et ça fait quand même un avantage la
perte de fou donc si moi j'ai cette
pollution avec les lents contre un genre
de mon élo je suis pas sûr de réussir à
faire quelque chose de cette position
parce que ça reste quand même assez égal
il y a plein de pièces tout ça par
contre tu mets ça à Magnus Magnus est
complètement capable de transformer
cette position et d'arriver à prendre
l'avantage avec cette paire de fou et
c'est un peu sa grande spécialité fado
c'est là où il est le plus fort c'est de
pousser des pollutions
ou beaucoup de joueurs se résigneraient
à faire mieux
pas de la dernière chose qu'il a vérifié
avant la ronde c'est justement ce qui a
joué Abdou voilà donc il la check mais
ça me suit en plus il a il a oublié
et
voilà bon saut contre Google est-ce que
ça joue est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils vont donner raison à
Hikaru qui disait que ça allait faire
quick draw
on n'a pas fait les petits pronostics
je t'appelle
2 le 2e sur Google
on a la position sous les yeux
j'avais pas vu le temps
j'avais pas vu le temps attention on a à
quel coup
c'est pour ça
mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai que nul
c'est un résultat qui est qui est
extrêmement logique
est-ce que c'est pas le moment de
prendre des risques de ton côté de
croire en Lui comme j'écris
j'arrête de me faire impressionner par
toi quoi
donc
j'ai envie de dire un zéro
ce qui serait horrible pour caravane
et à la fin
alité
S
de dessin qui allait être dans quel être
l'idée des Noirs mais tant que tu
arrives pas à le faire écoute moi je
vais faire ça ça tu pourras pas le faire
même qui avait laissé 7 au pire des cas
quand tu poussera je prends la manger
manger là écoute j'ai l'impression que
les que les Blancs ont une puissance tu
vois bien plus facile à jouer donc j'ai
envie de faire confiance
prenez le centre développez-vous là il
attend il attend avant de prendre le
centre il attend mais au final attention
à pas trop attendre parce que ça peut
être très dangereux et on peut
jamais réussir tout simplement
apprendre le centre l'espace à sortir
ses pièces
entre firou Fatou
va voir comment
à quel point on soutient ou non vas-y je
te laisse commencer
[Musique]
ai pas sur Paris déjà
je ne serai pas sur lui
je vais peut-être dire nul
le pas trop aujourd'hui Fatou
les dernières les dernières rondes
effectivement hier j'avais donné aucune
nul et il y a eu 4000 sur 5
donc
alors aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai parié
sur le sur le gain de firou parce qu'il
est mieux au temps et firou il va tout
tenter pour gagner même si c'est égal il
va essayer de jouer donc je me dis que
il peut il peut essayer de mettre la
pression on s'arrêter au tout à l'heure
on s'arrête à
7 alors souvent on fait du cavalier B4
cavaler ses deux pour venir piquer la
paire de fou avec la dame comme ça ok
fou G5 H6 H4 et 5 on va fermer les cases
il faut que j'ai trois tours 8 ok bon
quel potentiel de chaos de cette
position
histoire qu'elle est réserve du chaos
bah en fait je sais pas mais là c'est
vrai que pour l'instant tari il ferme le
centre OK
tes pièces des pièces en l'air de
partout comme on a pu le voir déjà un
petit peu avec lui avec tes tactiques
qui traînent
on va revenir par ici
et bon c'est quand même une position qui
est relativement ok pour les pour les
blancs généralement quand même
c'est solide quoi
mais il faut savoir quand même que dans
cette structure j'ai ce fou qui est
extrêmement mauvais
parce qu'il est derrière les pions il
arrive il a beaucoup de mal à
se mettre en place ce fou il est pas
terrible pour l'instant il y a plein de
fois je peux bouger mon cavalier jouer
F3 fois F2 pour revenir sur une
diagonale plus sympa
et chez les Noirs enfin tous tu mets des
couleurs et ben lui il est il est rouge
et il coûte
pas si bien non plus bon l'instant mais
une idée des Noirs ça peut être plus
tard éventuellement de jouer avec F5 de
ce côté là mais je rêve 5 pour ouvrir la
position ben écoute lui aussi il va
s'ouvrir
donc j'ai envie de dire que pour
l'instant les Noirs ont quand même
plutôt deux mauvais coup en fait
et les cavaliers
forcément on arrivera à faire quelque
chose de de nos fous mais c'est pas pour
tout de suite
reste assez thématique échanger ses
cavaliers et changer les pièces non ça
reste une position
de père de famille à la Free ciné c'est
plus tard
on se moque de l'eau mais Laurent hier
il a il a quand même battu
vent de Forest en Top 16 avec les Noirs
franchement belle partie de Laurent
qui fait un bon Top 16
je trouve c'est quand les noirs
attaquent le pion en 4
alors c'est long tout ça licorne un
cahier c'est un coup logique il veut
jouer F3 fois F2 et aussi il y a un
autre coup qui est intéressant pour les
blancs enfin un plan cavalier F1 cavalue
3 et éventuellement cavalier F5 alors
sympa
donc on se recycle un petit peu nos
pièces écoute moi j'aime bien cette
pollution pour les blancs perso et je
trouve que c'est plus facile pour les
blancs en tout cas à jouer parce que
j'ai plus d'espace
et alors pour le noir il faut vraiment
trouver un plan concret pour bien placer
les pièces en plus cavaler H5 qui aurait
pu être aussi une idée pour aller manger
de fou mais plus possible après cavaler
parce que je contrôle
ici
et planifient
mais attention que au final moi j'ai
quand même aussi mon fou qui peut venir
ici et ouvrir les cases les cases
blanches c'est possible mais je suis
prêt moi je suis prêt à s'ouvre donc
avoir
c'est compliqué
parfois tu as juste moins le coup donc
moins de choix et tu peux aller tu peux
jouer plus vite c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu contradictoire
quelque part mais tellement d'espace
donc tes coups sont plus fortes donc là
comme tu dis cavalier B8 cavalier 17
cavaliers C5 est-ce qu'on peut pas
gagner du temps à jouer en décou comme
ça un petit peu un petit peu pratique
sans dégrader la position en attendant
ça bouge pas aller à droite pas tout de
suite donc on a peut-être le temps et
tranquillement de conserver une avance
au temps et après de jouer la position
égale
pourrait potentiellement
craquer la stratégie
stratégie de faire patienter pour faire
craquer à la fin
dernière c'est vrai bon on donne ça va
s'ouvrir et puis faudra voir un peu mais
la pollution s'ouvrira pour les deux
camps et pas pour un seul
et Licorne qui nous dit si on joue un
truc de style food étroit tourcin pour
attaquer la dame C7
où ira cette dame noire et le fou B7
alors déjà un plan imaginons je vais
faire un truc comme ça juste pour pour
voir Vincent comme tour C1 on va
sûrement faire ici dame B8 avec
ID en fait bon continuer et peut-être
l'idée de faire cavalier c'est 5
et alors ce fou je sais pas encore où il
passera peut-être que je tourne cette
tour C8
[Musique]
on avait dit tout à l'heure le fou
pourrait se recycler sur cette diagonale
là et aussi on a essayé de tout
reprendre et donc c'est possible et donc
c'est vite
d'ailleurs j'ai vu une partie alors je
sais pas exactement cette position je
crois qu'il y avait un pion en C5 un peu
en C3 mais j'avais vu une fois une
partie alors je sais plus du tout de qui
c'était mais il y avait eu un sacrifice
de pièces en dessin avec un fou prends
et après un énorme centre des Noirs qui
était qui est avancé pour pour lutter
contre la pièce sacrifiée quand même
deux pions et le Centre pour la pièce
donc si jamais j'arrive à je sais pas en
tête préparer tout ça d'être un jour un
cavalier pour les cinq sera sera
possible avec un fou prend attaque là
attaque G2 il peut y avoir des
complications mais on est capable
ouais si on voit que c'est compliqué etc
bon on a vu encore hier et là ça fait
une qualité qu'on ne guérit il aime bien
sacrifier des pièces et s'il voit que
c'est intéressant bah écoute et qui peut
jouer pour le gain sans
faire trop line non plus il va faire
mais toi
donc ok Fatou
alors si on fait un petit tour donc on
vient d'y aller
seau on vient d'y aller aussi Nakamura
il s'est passé des choses Dame des cinq
de jouets de la part de Fabi donc il y a
un cama un clou ici mais le cavalier
pour l'instant il est suffisamment
défendu
comment est-ce qu'on continue Fatou
comment est-ce que tu continues avec les
Blancs
ensemble
ça va être compliqué
moi je vois deux coups
je sais pas
déjà première idée on veut essayer de
changer les pièces tant qu'à faire et
puis si en plus
en échangeant les pièges j'arrive à
défaire ma structure ça peut être encore
génial encore mieux
je pensais aussi à jouer B4
je peux laisser des plumes je suis pas
sûr du tout et je pensais aussi l'idée
de D4 ici et
sur des 4 mais l'idée c'est d'essayer de
profiter de ce
vis-à-vis ici
et je change des pions quoi
salut c'est mon train alors les clics de
sourire alors je vais essayer les
enlever et sans revenus alors je vais
voir ce que je peux faire
je vais voir ce que je peux faire
c'est le micro qui les capte
je vais voir si je peux changer alors
je suis en train de supprimer la langue
là c'est un peu normal
c'est intéressant comme ça que c'est
intéressant pour
pas laisser nous laisser jouer le bouger
le fou et puis être assez libre pour
bouger notre cavalier c'est simple après
j'essaye un petit peu de de
gagner du temps bouquin un petit peu
plus les blancs
mais c'est quand même compliqué il va
devoir être joué très actif et
agressif normalement avec le matos en
moins
mais pas évident et si on échange les
pièces ça c'est en la faveur des blancs
je sais pas après ton idée de T4
est-ce que tu as payé rendre un pion
si je peux rendre un pion
mais
échanger des trucs et surtout ma pièce
et rester qu'un peu plus à rien c'est
une idée que je peux avoir
on ne voit plus en fait c'est normal
t'inquiète pas
[Musique]
je suis en train de regarder mes
paramètres de Obs
de discorde et du coup j'ai enlevé parce
que
je sais plus comment je l'avais fait une
fois il y a un mode à faire
t'inquiète pas je suis dessus là est-ce
que là j'entendais mais clique de souris
quand je clique
on entend pas
toi tu entends pas mais
est-ce que vous entendez pas ça va être
là
parce qu'on m'avait dit que sur sur
discord il fallait mettre Chris c'est un
truc qui supprime le bruit de fond et
j'avais fait et après en même temps sur
Obs j'avais je suis allé dans les
filtres j'avais mis un truc de
j'avais mis un truc ok mais après des
fois comme je vous avais dit j'avais mon
micro qui avait enfin qui déconne quand
il déconne ça me détend et ça reprend
[Musique]
voilà donc apparemment
voilà
donc
c'est cool allez hop Fatou on te rend la
liberté et tu reviens voilà
parfait
nouvelle en bref Top 16 après avoir eu
plusieurs positions très favorables mais
je suis le risque de perdre contre
Mulhouse ou incroyable
avenir gagne 6-2 grâce à Clichy Santos
bord du match nul alors j'ai vu que
barbix avait l'air d'être complètement
gagnant tout à l'heure
j'ai vu avant de lancer le stream je
regardais un peu ça
a gagné d'ailleurs et Adrien de but a
gagné aussi
par contre
deux un pour l'instant sauf si
quand même
ou pas
comme prévu comme prédit
et comment on réagit comme ça avec les
Noirs là dessus
[Musique]
je pense que
c'est grâce
je pense la grâce va gagner un match
on parle du Top 16 c'est le
le championnat de France des clubs les
16 meilleures équipes et ses meilleurs
clubs qui s'affrontent en ce moment en
parallèle du Nord-Ouest c'est d'ailleurs
la bague
que je trouve certains de nos grands
champions français même si Ali Reza est
ici au nord et Jess
que je suis là j'appartie de l'euro
j'aime pas du tout et je pense qu'ils
sont vraiment en danger
[Musique]
l'équipe qui gagne
France qui risque de perdre un match
après ça reste encore pas fini il y a
encore des parties à jouer mais c'est
chaud ces choses
bon en tout cas nous on est quand même
sur le Norvège malheureusement pas
switché
est qualifié pour Top 16 l'année
prochaine donc l'année prochaine vous
verrez tout participer au Top 16
comme
fr qui sera là-bas
qui seront en Top 16
puissent puis tous les habituer donc
Libye cornette Laurent tracinet Kevin
thérieux
Étienne Bacro Sébastien Mazet et j'en
oublie peut-être encore
il y a vraiment du grand grand monde et
ça le clic au hasard salut à toi
ok
du coup il y a eu un petit deux fois le
coup qu'on avait proposé par un des
cours on est proposé qui paraît très
logique on veut changer les pièces il
n'a qu'à créer qui continue à ajouter
une grosse pression en temps il a 40
minutes d'avance sur Fabi
et deux pions de plus 40 minutes
d'avance pas tout ça commence à être
intéressant quand même ça commence à
faire mal surtout et qu'est-ce qu'on
joue avec les Noirs là moi j'ai le noir
je
pleure un petit peu
et ouais en plus Fabi qui
[Musique]
a été vraiment très surpris dans cette
dans cette ouverture
et
je pense que Naka a vraiment bien bien
visé dans cette prépa on y va perdre pas
mal de notes
beaucoup de notes et beaucoup de points
et l'eau
et c'est une partie qui aime beaucoup
d'enjeux qui se joue clairement l'enjeu
de gagner l'événement donc
au delà de ça bon il y a quand même pas
mal de prix vous savez les prix en
argent et au-delà de ça et ben on joue
aussi pour la deuxième place mondiale au
niveau de l’élo et pour l'instant la
première place est
occupée par par Fabienne Carona
[Musique]
mais en cas de victoire de Naka Naka il
serait deuxième sauf si vous abonner à
abattre un tarif ce serait les deux qui
seraient au coup d'un coup d'un impact
c'est pas clair qui serait devant fille
ou à un point de plus mais on gagne plus
de points en battant Caravana
G4 aussi mais après dame C4 l'échange
quand même les dames je suis pas sûr que
ce soit si bien que ça même si je fais
bon là il y a vraiment l'air mais si je
prends là
les pâtes savoir de quoi je prends
si je prends d'un pion j'ai peur que le
courage
c'est pas se sentir
la situation mais on n'oublie pas que tu
as deux pions de plus donc tu as pas
envie de rendre l'eau actif et si tu
dois y laisser un pion c'est pas grave
vaut mieux garder l'activité
arriéré puis aussi le tour prend F4 qui
est possible je vois bien
un coup
donc oui non non
[Musique]
cette partie dans la position et autant
enfin tu vois
oui et autant ça fait mal il fait mal à
tout j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour toi
une confession c'est pas vrai et devine
devine de qui on a reçu la confession
pas tout attends je réfléchis je
réfléchis allez au hasard maca c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile à deviner et tu
as et tu as vu juste Fatou je reçois une
confession de Nakamura qui entre ses
coups et décide de venir se balader et
faire des petites confessions sur sur
ces parties donc est-ce que tu veux
qu'on aille voir ça enfin tout est-ce
que ça t'intéresse est-ce que tu es
curieuse savoir ce que ce que Naka
aurait pu nous dire dans toutes ses
confessions très curieuse de savoir ce
qu'ils pensent des parties et de sa
propre partie qui est qui est la partie
décisive pour le pour la première place
du placement donc là il vient de
s'asseoir je pense que il vient de
rentrer de la compétition à l'instant il
revient ils sont inversés vient juste de
jouer il perd même pas de temps en
allant au confessionnal
allez on parle on parle aussi partout
allez c'est parti allez je vous mets la
confession dans un instant ce n'est oups
me tromper je m'explique
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec cette partie
alors je me suis trompé de caméra j'ai
pris celle là et donc rapidement alors
Naka il est assez content de la position
qu'il a alors l'idée qu'il était un
petit peu confus
il disait que il y avait une ligne ici
avec cavalier B4 et surtout prends plus
on prend cavalier ici Dame des 5
D4 ou V4 et il dit que dans cette
position
ils vont arriver dans une finale qui
sera
peut-être légèrement mis à jour pour les
Noirs je crois de ce qu'il a dit mais
rien de spécial et pense bon nul OK et
en fait ça maintenant il a pas du tout
jouer ça il a joué F5 et il dit F5 pour
moi c'est nouveau je ne connais pas ce
n'est pas dans mon dossier donc 10 fois
que c'est pas en son dossier donc
plusieurs raisons soit il a mal fait son
travail et il a raté un coup dans ton
dossier c'est que si hyper et ben il
peut se blâmer que lui-même parce qu'il
n'aura pas travaillé ce que F5 qui peut
être un coup principal soit
qu'avec français 5 il mange un deuxième
pion et il dit bah écoute je mange le
pion je verrai et il y a une raison si
le coup n'est pas dans mon fichier c'est
que quand même
son coup tu as pas de bon donc il bête
il Paris sur le fait que Caravana s'est
trompé lui-même attends dans la théorie
il a envie de faire confiance quand même
à son fichier et et à dire que ben il
pense est beaucoup il disait que il y a
des positions ou des fois les blancs
prennent ces 5 avec le cavalier et la
Tour Blanche étant A1 et il dit que des
fois c'est un peu ça peut être compliqué
parce que vu qu'il y a ce clouage sur
cette diagonale et ben ça peut être
problématique tout en a parlé dans cette
position quand on va voir ça un petit
peu on a parlé que si jamais j'arrivais
par exemple à faire
on a dit tout à l'heure cloître ça peut
être problématique et il dit que avec la
tour en 1 donc dans cette position après
F5 il dit bah ouais mais c'est ma tour
était ici il y aurait un problème de
plage peut-être qu'il y aura des
complications mais que la tour ancien il
pense que c'est pas du tout grave et il
pense que il est très bien donc il est
pas sûr il toute façon ça va être une
grosse baston cette partie et que il
veut gagner la partie et donc il est
très content d'avoir une pollution ou
c'est hyper chaud contre Nakamura parce
que c'est tout ce qu'il
voulait dans cette partie pour essayer
de jouer le gain du tournoi
donc voilà je crois que j'ai bien résumé
n'a qu'à pour son talent pas mis pour le
sérieux et son travail il mérite tous
les deux là d'être champion du monde
mais seulement il y a un alien le Magnus
par confirme ça c'est un nouveau fit
mais il est alors il est instable et du
moins il me donne pas ce qu'il faut
impression pardon avant pour ses
supporters
ok alors moi je vais vous donner mon
avis à moins que tu veux dire ton avis
pas tout qu'est-ce que tu penses de des
messages sur le chat
[Musique]
en fait j'aime
beaucoup d'aller tout en haut de
champion du monde après les autres l'ont
pas grand chose à dire Magnus il
est trop fort il a su s'imposer après
il y a plein de joueurs très sérieux
que dire de plus non
génération avec Magnus et bon bah juste
en affaire
peut-être une autre génération on a
peut-être pu passer c'est que Caravana
pendant très très longtemps c'était
clairement le numéro de mondial qui
aurait peut-être pu être en compte du
monde
en tout cas c'était clairement le numéro
2 derrière un
et d'ailleurs le match contre carcène
donc bon
Naka c'est un joueur qui qui de ce que
je sais c'est pas un énorme bosseur donc
bah d'ailleurs
de base c'est un joueur qui
assez découragé à un moment donné quand
il fallait trop bosser les ouvertures
pour ça il préférait les parties où il y
avait moins d'ouverture ou les parties
rapides ils préfèrent parce qu'il y a
beaucoup moins de travail de fonds dans
les ouvertures à faire mais Naka il est
extrêmement talentueux et mais après
aussi
tu peux être très talentueux très doué
et si il travaille pas suffisamment
et ben tu ne pourras pas être au top top
niveau et après je pense que le fait de
vouloir et avoir le l'ambition et et la
motivation pour travailler autant
l'échec c'est aussi quelque chose qui
est important dans les échecs et c'est
aussi un don que tu peux avoir il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont pas envie de
finir ton travail ou qui est un petit
peu la flemme et si je vois là et bien
ils pourront pas de champion du monde
donc le fait d'avoir envie et d'aimer
travailler autant et ben c'est vrai que
c'est aussi c'est aussi une forme de de
surdoué comme il dit ici RKM mais c'est
vrai que c'est une forme un peu de génie
quoi tu vois parce que tu peux être plus
grand génie de tous les temps si tu
aimes pas travailler les déchets et ben
tu le feras pas sympa mais je pense la
capacité à vraiment pouvoir travailler
plusieurs jours par jour être hyper
rigoureux c'est aussi quelque chose qui
qui est pas donné à tout le monde et
c'est quelque chose qui est difficile à
faire et à produire et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on a qu'à n'a jamais été vraiment
va vraiment au top top niveau salut
Robinson
mais voilà par contre comparer Furious
juja avec Naka Caravana bon je pense que
là il y a absolument aucun
aucun intérêt ferroger et nous il a 19
ans quand même 19 ans
il veut toutes ces parties à fond blanc
noir vous avez vu la partie bancaire il
a voulu rentrer dedans quoi enfin il l'a
pas sous-estimé donc j'ai vu ça c'est
pas qui sous-estime c'est qu'il a il a
juste pas peur en fait
ils veulent champion du monde donc si tu
veux être champion du monde à un moment
donné il faut pas avoir peur et il faut
y aller et c'est gagné toute la partie
et on peut apprécier c'est parti donc
vous allez voir qu'on a enfin que que
filou hyper beaucoup plus de parties que
d'autres joueurs mais il engage aussi
beaucoup plus et son style de jeu il a
19 ans et voilà donc
donc regardez un peu Carlsen comment il
jouait à 19 ans c'est un style
différente qui était plus solide que les
filles Rosa actuellement mais
bon après il gagnait moins de partie
aussi tu vois donc là comparé firouza
avec Caruana et Nakamura qui sont j'ai
envie de dire quasiment pas tout bon ils
sont je peux pas dire qu'ils sont en
train de carrière non mais j'ai pas
d'accès de carrière ils ont encore la
fontaine quoi tu vois mais bon il y a 15
ans d'écart il y a 15 ans entre
Fabi il est de 92 je crois 92 Fabi donc
il doit avoir actuellement 31 ans et il
y a 12 ans 12 ans de plus 12 ans de plus
que
les filles il a le temps quand même en
12 ans d'arriver quoi et Nakamura il est
quelle année je dirais 87 86 je dirais
c'est comme ça donc ça fait quoi
donc c'est vraiment c'est un peu comme
Robinson quoi c'est la classe au-dessus
quoi
oui il y a 15 ans il y a plus de 15 ans
[Musique]
donc non non mais ok c'est pas la même
génération en fait on peut pas comparer
c'est comme c'est là que vous voulez me
comparer à Google avec des pommes
natiques
qui sort de l'oeuf bon en fait ça fait
un moment quand même que firou il est au
top top niveau
parce qu'il a 2800 mais bon il est hyper
jeune en fait donc la maturité de ses
coups même dans ces décisions il fait au
lit dans toutes ces parties
bah ouais mais bon
c'est un style de jeu et peut-être que
plus tard il va mûrir il va être plus
solide il va changer son nom tu vas
comprendre que jouer solide des fois
c'est pas mal il en prend hyper jeune
donc en fait
[Musique]
je sais pas mais c'est incomparable en
fait c'est comparable
[Musique]
vécu dans une autre génération que
c'était de Magnus il aurait peut-être pu
être champion du monde d'ailleurs
maintenant Magnus qui a abandonné
abandonné le cycle du champion du monde
la coûte peut-être que maintenant
carwana il se dit matin il y a il y a un
spot quoi
[Musique]
la génération de Magnus malheureusement
pour eux et ben il y en a beaucoup qui
ont des fois
l'idée d'essayer de passer enfin d'être
champion du monde parce que c'est
beaucoup trop dur mais maintenant que
Magnus se retire et ben tu peux avoir
une émulation au niveau du top 10 pour
dire bon les gars maintenant moi je peux
y aller quoi tu vois exactement et c'est
ce qu'on dit ils sont tous dans un mou
ça veut aussi dire quelque chose là il y
en a il y en a plus d'un je pense qu'il
veut sortir du lot et essayer de se
rapprocher de de carrousel
c'est compliqué
les jeunes les jeunes n'ont peut-être
plus de chances de tirer dans l'épingle
du jeu là dedans
de gagner un gros tournoi pour la
confiance non mais il avait 2800 et
l'eau il y a quelques mois
il a quand même gagné plein de tournois
et puis il a quand même démontrer quoi
enfin je pense en termes de confiance
je pense que ça va quoi je pense que il
y a pire quand même avoir 2800 hello à
19 ans d'ailleurs il avait il avait 18
ans quand il a quand il est passé
en Europe par équipe où il avait un fait
un peu de 6 émissaire
la France qui a fait médaille de de
bronzes il me semble Fatou ou d'argent
je sais plus ce championnat d'Europe par
équipe j'ai un doute et
il est au courant de tout ça avec un
filou qui devant gagner toutes ces
parties donc
bon il a il a quand même
je argent du Robinson avec il a quand
même confirmé puis une fois donc on peut
pas
t'as pas de 1800 euros par hasard en
fait tu vois son vélo il est là quoi
donc non il a confirmé après bien sûr
c'est vrai que gagner un tournoi ça fait
toujours plaisir et ça à croire un petit
peu clairement ton
assurance et tout ça mais bon film ça va
quoi je pense que ça fait son éloge
effectivement un petit peu et
j'aurais bien aimé le voir contre lui
je contredis en maths hyper optimiste il
veut tout gagner il veut tout jouer et
c'est un tu vois la partie qu'ils ont
joué ensemble Magnus il est venu au
conditionnel en disant ouais
c'est marrant je le contre quelqu'un qui
qui joue hyper original au bout de trois
coups martiaux enfin juste c'est génial
c'est ce qu'il voulait en fait et
alors que le lendemain bah il joue
contre ma médias rock et il a eu les
noirs
que tu préfères juste voilà et donc des
fois c'est décevant il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui qui font nuls pour ma nu
c'est prise en poche leur un point et
demi et l'eau sans prendre la tête et
puis ça fait un droit de repos etc ma
venue c'est que noir des fois rien faire
ils sont trop forts gagner avec les
noirs des fois c'est en fait
les joueurs à 2451
ont les blancs contre Magnus et Voltaire
nuls ça fait nul parce que c'est
difficile quasiment impossible de gagner
avec les Blancs à que noir contre ce
type de joueur à ce niveau-là et donc
Magnus apprécie énormément les joueurs
qui veulent lui coller ils veulent le
battre parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui font un petit peu
les pleutres pour être poli contre lui
parce que c'est quand même le meilleur
joueur du monde et beaucoup de gens ont
peur ils veulent pas se prendre la tête
donc voilà
peut-être donc pour c'est un BK
candidats alors B4 d'un côté c'est un
cookie permet de défendre ce cavalier de
remplacer le fou peut-être de le solide
mais après mes quatre faut regarder à 5
et après à 5
il faut il faut calculer tout simplement
je sais pas ce que ça donne et après à 5
moi j'ai envie quand même et j'ai
l'impression quand même que j'obtiens un
peu de contrôle sur la colonne avec un
noir
pas totalement sur que ce soit une bonne
idée tu vois il y a tout qui se casse un
peu la gueule toi
en tout cas visuellement ça me plaît pas
trop vous pouvez jouer plusieurs coups
d'affilée je te dirai B4 ça ça et ben je
le ferai avec grand plaisir mais
maintenant je suis
voilà
totalement sûr par ça Descartes un autre
point intéressant permet de donner un
pion mais d'ouvrir des colonnes et
encore une fois pour calculer ça donne
un pion
après tu retiens à la Russie pas mal de
développement
et
pas contre de l'activité adverse voilà
si jamais je peux donner en disant quand
on fait ça et après je fais ça et puis
j'arrive à stabiliser et regarder mon
pion de plus à la limite ça peut être un
choix pas mal de la part de Nakamura
pour vraiment
garder son avantage maintenant il y a ce
clouage qui m'embête quand même pas mal
surtout âge là et là je serai même en
train d'essayer de calculer
des coûts du
type la cavalière A4 alors tactiquement
ça n'a pas marché je pense que
mais j'explique un petit peu l'idée
l'idée c'est que bon il laisse le flou
mais tu découvres celui-là et si jamais
j'arrivais par exemple à faire ça et à
réussir de stabiliser la position
et garder mes pions ça peut être pas mal
de fou qui il va se réveiller aussi
peut-être que c'est pas si simple encore
de temps on a quand même des pions qui
sont très très faibles avec les Blancs
donc certes ils sont en plus mais si
jamais je les perds et que les Noirs
arrivent à s'activer enfin tout ça peut
devenir
tout à fait mais on garde en tout cas
cette option
le cavalier C6 en vue donc
potentiellement d'échanger le four à
trois contre le Carlier c'est 6 à voir
si ça reste faisable comme un autre
resto
une fois que j'ai fait simple bouger
et essayer de fur et à mesure se défaire
tout ça et même rendre un pion à un
moment donné quand je des pièces voilà
c'est un plan qui qui a clairement un
intérêt et qui pourra peut-être être
d'actualité dans quelques groupes tout
n'est pas pressé tout ressens c'est un
peu de dire bah à toi de jouer et c'est
toi qui a du mal à sortir tes pièges
chez les Noirs qu'est-ce que tu fais
exactement et puis nous on se repère
tranquillement on va défendre notre
cavalier bouger notre fou et ça va y
aller travailler
peut-être simplement
alors
pour Marius donc si c'est vraiment la
partie pour la première place et si
karwana perd Hikaru le dépasse
on a montré le classement on vous
montrera maintenant plus tard mais c'est
la partie c'est la partie décisive donc
là
car wanna il a pas le droit
on vous rappelle le les points les
formats je pense que je peux l'avoir ici
un format
ça c'est le format par contre je vais
pas malheureusement
les règles
bien traduit par notre ami Robinson donc
je vais pas faire honneur enfin
malheureusement dans mon Obs je n'ai pas
ça mais en fait pour faire un petit peu
un petit peu le les points si vous
voulez le barème en cas de victoire
classique ça veut dire partie lente on a
actuellement ici à l'écran et ben il y a
trois points de match c'est à dire que
si
karunakamura qui affronte avec les
blancs car wanna si Carole Nakamura
gagne la partie lente et ben gagne 3
points
ce qui veut dire qui passerait devant un
carbonara qui sera coiffé au poteau avec
0 point donc voilà donc 7 points si on
peut mettre le nul on a un point chacun
et ensuite on va joindre Armageddon avec
10 minutes contre 7 minutes
pour un demi point bonus donc souvent on
voit des résultats tels que un point
contre 1 et demi par exemple ça va comme
ça
et donc voilà c'est la grosse partie il
y en a qu'à moi il sait qu'il doit
gagner cette partie en classique pour
gagner le tournoi s'il gagne et ben ils
saurule ça jugera pardon le nord-ouest
2023 en cas de non-victoire et ben c'est
karwana qui gagnera l'événement voilà
donc pardon on va revenir à notre
parcillon regarder la partie de la casse
la 3
et derrière il y a Google qui a saut il
y a bien du monde derrière donc
effectivement c'est compliqué
pas de quoi se construire si tu veux un
petit tour très rapidement d'échiquier
avant de faire une petite pause ça te va
parfait pour moi parfait pour toi allez
on passe vite voir Magnus contre à torov
donc cette partie on a déjà vu un peu
cette position tout à l'heure ma minus
qui avait la tour en B1 donc on pensait
voir un becatriver rapidement mais c'est
l'option ça pourrait être en prise donc
Magnus qui a la paire de fou quand même
c'est un petit avantage sur le long
terme on va voir si Marius va réussir à
mettre la pression dans cette partie on
peut imaginer comme F3
jouer à l'instant par Magnus
de Magnus
ok donc F3
jouer à un instant à un donc je voulais
souffler dans l'oreille
donc F3 5 qui a l'air très fort parce
que ça va contrôler la case de 4 qui
était contrôlé par ce cavalier parce
qu'à valoir donc on va chasser ouvrir
dans notre diagonale et pouvoir
commencer un petit peu à replacer les
pièces donc peut-être un tour Eiffel
derrière ou F2 et petit à petit prends
le contrôle de la colonne ouverte
replacer les fous d'être chasser l'autre
plus tard replacer les cours sur les
bonnes cases et à un moment donné
peut-être essayer de pousser les pions
un peu vers l'avant
donc c'est une position qui est à peu
près égale 1000 à l'avantage des deux
fous ça peut peut-être lui porter
un petit peu pour essayer d'avoir une
une finale favorable avec sa paire de
fou
encore rien mettre extraordinaire mais
c'est un avantage enfin c'est une des
positions qu'il adore pousser et très
technique donc je pense que c'est un
truc qui peut on dirait que ça m'a un
qui peut gagner cette position avec les
Blancs c'est bien lui
donc une position à deux résultats
première victoire on n'oublie pas il est
encore jamais gagné
avec un peu poussé à miser sur un Google
qui est
relativement
égale
mais il y a la part de fou chez les
Noirs si tu prends ici la structure
change un petit peu
disons que Google a quand même beaucoup
de temps d'avance à la pendule donc il
reste encore combien de temps à faire
20 coups à jouer pour 33 minutes pour
Wesley ton Wesley qui peut ok
mais après il essaie de d'avancer ça
reste égal mais
c'est le sight note qui peut faire la
différence donc on avance lentement vers
la finale mais sinon ça peut ça peut
être facilement vers la nul ouais ça
c'est égal moi je crois pas trop qui je
crois pas trop un gain de goûter même si
j'aimerais beaucoup mais je pense que ça
va fermer le Fatou
donc la partie de Nakamura Fabi je pense
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure
avantage et on attend avec un patience
la prochaine confession de Naga donc on
vous tient au courant 4e
Paris sur si les Noirs arrivent pas à
jeter 5
en fait il a pas réussi
hop E5 empêcher les 5 à regarder sur D5
ici il y a la prise en passant beaucoup
de gens ne savent pas ce que c'est que
la présentation alors je vous la prends
rapidement c'est quand un pionce de
cases pardon et que à côté de lui et
qu'il a bougé et ben il se retrouve à
côté d'un pion adverse à ce moment-là et
seulement à ce moment-là c'est le droit
de capturer en diagonale le pion qui
n'était pas en diagonale d'ailleurs et
je mange le pion si en juin D5 le plan
de deux cases vous voyez bien ici les
pions étaient une case et fait
maintenant des 5 et ben il va voir que
d'une seule case au dernier coup je ne
pourrez pas manger en diagonale ici
parce que le pion avance de une seule
case si le pion fait deux cases à la
fois je pourrais manger et si il prend
un dessin quelque je mange pas de suite
et ben prochain coup je ne pourrais pas
manger parce que je peux manger que sur
que sur le
d'accord c'est que un moment qui fait
des cinq que j'ai pas de manger donc E5
qui empêche du coup là où ces dessins
parce que je prendrai un passant F6 ça a
été joué prise et fidésis et maintenant
encore une fois les Noirs n'arrivent pas
à jouer des 5 donc là c'est fou que
reposer pas tout mais c'est fou qui qui
est vraiment pris misérable d'armes des
trois logiques on va défendre ce petit
pion on va faire le tour en E1 une
torale placée un fou qui joue pas Fatou
j'ai envie de dire que la pollution est
très très mal embarquée pour un média
off
pas du tout même chez les noirs on va
voir comment il va réussir à sortir de
là chasser le fou peut-être
du Tour
tout aussi
se met les couches
j'arrive à temps
après c'est une position
en fait
si je donnais qu'un seul pion c'était
possible parce qu'en fait tout la
colonne
en fait ce qui est important dans ces
potions à reposer
en milieu de jeu et ben il faut jouer
sur sa couleur et des pions n'ont pas
tant d'importance que ça il est plus
important c'est l'activité des pièces
donc c'est vrai que tu arrives plus à
bouger et que ton fou est pourri c'est
pourri un moment donné tu vas avoir
envie de dire pour éviter quoi vas-y
ciao
ça peut être possible dire ok allez et
maintenant je vais jouer un coup et plus
tard mon four ici et mon actif
voilà et de plus en plus pour les blancs
mais la structure ici est pourrie il y a
toujours un petit peu de de d'activité
quoi donc en tout cas ça peut être une
possibilité j'y crois pas trop de ces 5
dessins mais pas tout ton coup était pas
débile du tout parce que clairement
les Noirs veulent s'activer d'une
manière ou d'une autre
non non
mais dans l'idée s'activer au prix du
matériel c'est c'est tout à fait dans
l'esprit des
ok
c'est notre français
qui joue le plan qu'on avait on avait
parlé de G6 et dames B8 c'est exactement
ce qu'on avait dit tout à l'heure là
fais attention on est au 28e coups et
tari
pardon il lui reste plus que 36 minutes
donc hop c'est un peu tout ça attends
non pardon il n'a pas vu
on était comme ça et en fait au final il
a mis la dame ailleurs
ici pour venir échanger le bon cavalier
en F4 des noirs
raté
de pouvoir
pousser moi j'aime bien ce coup D2 la
moins pousser un peu sur la diagonale
c'est très intéressant
et écoute j'ai l'impression qu'ici
à faire sortir ce petit plan est-ce que
je trouve C8 ou est-ce que je trouve ces
8 ans on a parlé pas tout éviter
peut-être un jour de faire F5
ça on prend un casque
sa vie de cité case en C1 un jour
ok bonne position en tout cas qui est
totalement
jouable ici ok pas tout est-ce qu'on se
fait une petite pause mettre deux heures
qu'on est là on n'a pas encore fait de
pause
un petit
on a quelques nouvelles aussi du
avec peut-être gagner en tout cas moi je
veux regarder ça pendant
les Noirs donc cruellement d'espace
on en parle à notre tour si tu veux
à tout de suite à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier sur
plusieurs du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title
tuesday.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour
nous revoilà
pour vous jouer un mauvais tour
et oui on connaît
[Musique]
plutôt faire vivre un entraîneur les
champs humains et vrais conseils il y a
que ça oui pour ceux qui sont pas en
club qui ne qui
joue que sur Internet franchement moi je
peux que vous recommander et je pense
que tout aussi d'aller
en club d'aller rencontrer des vrais
gens d'aller échanger sur le jeu entre
entre passionnés entre amateurs et
professionnel aussi et effectivement un
entraîneur il y a
que ça devrait en tout cas c'est bien et
quand on veut apprendre vraiment on
pourra prendre il faut comprendre aussi
et pour comprendre rien de mieux qu'une
explication une belle explication
humaine de quelqu'un qui s'y connaît
donc je t'apprends là-dessus Christ
[Musique]
si vous êtes passionné par l'échec mais
vous n'avez jamais fait de club allez
allez dans un club il y a plein de
tournois il y a plein de trucs qui vous
rencontrent des gens et c'est beaucoup
beaucoup mieux que de jouer sur internet
à la maison j'imagine que
c'est clair c'est clair mais après je
dis ça très mauvais club dans ce cas-là
oui comme ça ça peut arriver moi j'ai eu
des élèves qui que j'ai encouragé dans
des clubs ça c'est pas forcément bien
placé bien placé
parce que le club en question était pas
forcément très agréable des fois c'est
débutant des fois les débutants enfin
dans ce cas là c'était une femme et
débutante je vais pas mal en plus et il
était très content qu'une femme qui
arrive dans le club parce que c'est dans
plein de compétitions
complètement laissé tomber et
c'est très moche et donc voilà bon son
histoire et du coup elle veut plus y
aller elle habite loin de tous les
autres clubs c'est le seul capital très
très loin je sais plus où mais pas la
campagne et du coup ben elle a plus
envie de faire de clubs
mais voilà si vous êtes si vous avez en
tout cas envie de vous approcher des
clubs motivé et bien sûr passionné
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à demander moi
aussi parce que même dans le chat si
vous voulez on peut discuter moi je
connais quand même enfin à tout aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
de clubs donc si vous habitez dans un
endroit
[Musique]
à l'endroit précis je peux
éventuellement vous guider vers des
clubs qui sont sympas et je connais
beaucoup de monde des gens aussi qui
travaillent comme entraîneur dans
certains cas aussi et je peux vous
guider et vous envoyer vers des des gens
et des clubs qui sont compétents bien
sûr on peut y aller via la Fédération
trouver des lieux précisément mais nous
aussi on connaît comme il l'a dit on
s'est un petit peu où aller où
où il y a des gens des gens sympathiques
qui vont bien vous accueillir dans quel
coin etc donc en tout cas n'hésitez pas
il y a aussi des cours qui sont proposés
par le club et pour tout niveau tout âge
des compétitions individuelles par
équipe plan rapide Blitz tout ce que
vous voulez mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut on peut carrément
trouver son bonheur et
les petits cours les cours collectifs et
tout dans les clubs les petits tournois
de Blitz etc c'est vraiment super sympa
il faut pas avoir peur il y en a qui ont
peur qu'ils disent bon je préfère
progresser avant d'aller en club pour
arriver en club et pas tout perdre quoi
mais je pense qu'il faut pas le voir
comme ça vous êtes débutant bah les
débutants on s'assume quoi faut y aller
et c'est en allant en club qu'on va plus
facilement apprendre
beaucoup plus vite en allant en club il
y a des gens qui vont vous aider à
progresser et si vous faites l'inverse
si vous avez peur d'aller en club et que
vous restez à la maison en disant bon je
progresser un peu à la maison et après
j'irai en club mais en fait vous irez
jamais en club enfin là
puis vous vous limitez quoi alors que
vous savez que tout le monde enfin tous
les joueurs d'échec on a tous commencé
en étant débutant même Minecraft et ben
je vais vous dire une chose quarantaine
il est pas né le champion du monde voilà
ça vous le savez peut-être pas mais
est-ce qu'il est né comme tout le monde
enfant bébé et il a il a il a il Sark
dans un club très cher qu'il a fait des
tournois il est très doué etc voilà mais
mais voilà
donc c'est c'est important très très
important d'ailleurs et ça va vous aider
à beaucoup progresser et à vous épanouir
dans votre activité peu importe l'âge
que vous avez peu importe votre niveau
n'hésitez pas à aller en club écris ce
qui a loupé on répondait justement à ce
que tu disais en tout cas mon
rebondissait sur ce que tu disais
priorité au direct non non mais vas-y
vas-y je vais essayer de comprendre
pendant que tu parles
ah c'est très marrant ça
sur la colonne C les pensées donc comme
souffle disait peut-être aussi avec du
des idées de fousser vite pour aller
pousser S5 à un moment et ouvrir mais il
a pas fait comme
comme ce qu'on avait pu imaginer et il
est allé jouer à l'aile allait le droit
très rapidement et maintenant on
comprend on comprend pourquoi donc il a
ramené ces pièces petit à petit à
l'endroit et là les petites tactiques
dans l'air et il va balancer
quels sont les derniers coups qu'on peut
remontrer ce qui a été joué ça c'est
c'est toi qui le joue c'est pas le
direct
ça attaque clairement ça fait une
fourchette ça mange un pion ça mange pas
n'importe quel pion un seul pion du roi
surtout pour la 5 bien sûr ici j'ai un
projet 5 et en plus je fais une
découverte donc ça a l'air pas mal du
tout il faut quand même vérifier
cavalier je crois Fatou
il y en a que Madame
je bouge madame je perds le cavalier ça
peut
ça
tienne et quand tu manges mon cavalier
je mange ton cavalier
ça va pouvoir être pas mal j'ai mangé un
plomb avec les noix et puis comme la
colonne
qui sont pas terribles sur le fou qui
est toujours mauvais et le mien qui va
pouvoir plus tard s'en sortir et
éventuellement avoir la fameuse rupture
avec capsule et d'un seul coup les
pièces les pièces noires prennent après
une carré dans le sens
plein d'avenir
du coup
reprenait
chaque qui attaque la tour et le roi
cavalier j'ai quatre forces c'est pas
toi si je bouge le roi je perds la porte
[Musique]
et je vais manger le cavalier alors j'ai
qu'à marcher 4 encore qui se regarde
mais H4 par exemple on peut l'imaginer
un peu pour essayer de déstabiliser de
la dame pour pas qu'elle puisse attaquer
la toux par exemple si je fais ça la
tour elle est plus emprise par la dame
donc je pourrais maintenant peut-être
bouger mon Caval quelque part là où là
je sais pas où et le remplacer par
contre le coup sur sur H4 sûrement d'un
F4 pour regarder le contact avec la
tours
en même temps c'est ça et donc et quand
je vais manger ici bien évidemment alors
peut-être sur H5 alors je sais pas faut
voir ce que tu fais mais peut-être par
exemple comme dame 2 pour défendre la
tour après puis on prend bah écoute les
blancs donc là matériellement on égalité
mais d'un autre côté
Laurent Blanc est devenu hyper faible la
structure qui s'est quand même pas mal
endommagé et bien c'est noir qui sont
vachement activés et les pièces blanches
qui restent pas très belles donc j'ai
envie de dire que que
une position très intéressante et qui
peut peut-être jouer pour le gain
de lire ce qui s'est passé rapidement
c'est vraiment dommage il ne faut
négliger personne j'ai commencé à jouer
en club à 11 ans à l'époque ah mince ça
bouge en même temps incroyable
président est sorti en me disant tu veux
rentrer pour jouer je lui ai dit je n'ai
pas de sous il a souri il m'a dit tu
n'as pas besoin ici viens t'amuser quand
tu veux aujourd'hui je suis président
d'association d'associations et je redis
la même chose aux enfants aux adultes
qui n'ont pas d'argent lorsqu'il pousse
la porte c'est beau ce que tu dis
licorne le miracle du partage et de la
bienveillance et on aime les gens comme
toi licorne ça fait plaisir
s'il te plaît avec plaisir
présente on dit en regardant mon dossier
c'est vous le joueur d'échec j'ai dit
oui ils se sont regardés ils se sont
regardés en regardant les résultats des
tests que je venais de passer ils m'ont
dit bienvenue chez nous en me souriant
je vous échecs c'est le meilleur jeu du
monde le roi des jeux
alors juste bon ça c'est clair c'est un
peu tous ces petits messages qui sont
vraiment cool et c'est ton histoire
aussi est vraiment géniale de licorne et
aussi un truc marrant c'est que
il y a beaucoup de gens donc peut-être
pas voilà pour toi moi je me mets mais
il y a beaucoup de gens qui pensent
que j'ose aux échecs et ben ça fait très
sérieux donc c'est sur les CV sur plein
de
très souvent quand je partais en tournoi
par exemple etc et que je louais un
Airbnb bon voilà il y a marqué pas de
tête dans l'appartement pas de
célébration etc
je fais un genre d'échec et en fait ils
savent pas que je souffle dans voilà et
tout ça pour dire en fait que très
souvent tu dis que tu es genre l'échec
ça fait très sérieux les gens qui sont
pas je vois des chèques mais s'il le
savait et ben
des centaines d'anecdotes comme ça
genre d'échec effectivement
si je l'ai fait j'ai réservé des gîtes
pour les tournois bon tu lui mets tu lui
mets je viens pour un tournoi d'échec tu
es obligé de le mettre parce que tu sais
tu as une facilité de passage quoi et
ouais en fait ils savent pas que vous
êtes tous pareils quoi
en fait vous allez faire n'importe quoi
mais
ça fait très sérieux moi j'ai toujours
fait ça
une histoire ou un garçon propose de
payer une poupée à sa petite sœur le
marchand le devant de combien il a une
petite histoire de coquillages ça peut
on y répond qu'il en a trop et lui rend
quelques-uns en monnaie c'est des belles
histoires salut free bird
ave bah écoute j'ai l'impression qu'elle
va être pas mal non
il y a eu des coups
oui
[Musique]
alors effectivement en regardant un jeu
je vais essayer de passer des trucs là
et là on a récupéré le pion avec les
Blancs c'est vrai mais le noir sont
assez actifs le cavaler est pas terrible
ici le fou c'est le mauvais fou ou
peut-être qu'un jour soit changer les
cavaliers soit par cavalier F6 passer
par là et même ramener une tour par ici
peut-être faire un truc
mais si il a joué à la place elle va les
prendre les deux il a été gourmand
il a donné le pion D6 et alors ça c'est
un gros pari qui vient de faire parce
que manger des six ça a l'air à l'air
chaud très très chaud parce que ben
c'est protégé quand même ici et
là tout en plus elle est en prise en
donc
[Musique]
je continue
par rapport à la position
[Musique]
de foot pas si bon que ça
en tout cas la chose qui
[Musique]
la joueuse qui
s'enflamme énormément à cause de cette
diagonale blanche qui est ouverte ça
peut jouer des tours passer protégé voir
concrètement de la colonne de la
diagonale qu'est-ce que je fais
et un coup j'aime bien
les allers-retours si facilement c'est
vrai que c'est
ça fait peur tout ça mais bon à voir
mais c'est vrai que par principe
on donne pas trop le puis on insiste
comme ça
assez naturel
qui a l'air plus sympa
il a peut-être vu quelque chose
que ça ça joue toujours on n'y est pas
il a aussi un peu perdu de son de son
avance au temps
mais
avoir avoir
si parce qu'il a calculé là dessus
ça me plaît pas trop je rejoins Dav pour
[Musique]
ça que les gens étaient pas convaincus
effectivement
alors Fatou j'avais pas vu mais en fait
sur le dans le slack et ben il y avait
stock qui a pénible entre Google et
l'Armageddon qui a commencé depuis déjà
7 minutes
et du coup je l'ai pas vu en arrivant
donc ça c'est la position de
l'Armageddon entre deux joueurs je vais
vous mettre la je vais vous mettre aussi
la les joueurs
en vidéo donc les noirs doivent faire
nul pour gagner l'Armageddon c'est la
dernière partie je pense qu'il est
important parce que là peut-être que
avec la nul Google rattraper les gens ou
pas on va regarder
alors ça lui prie Birds vraiment
horrible non ça reste là pour voir une
fois que la prise des sites a été faite
le fou peut revivre donc la question
c'est pas dans le recrutement je te
promets que les gens assimilent
intelligence aux échecs et ouais mais
pourtant marche pas d'accord
alors par contre ça ça m'intéresse je
j'ai enfin il y en a plusieurs
conseillés mais la salsa
moi je parle espagnol donc du coup c'est
vrai que il manque un petit peu ce truc
là mais je crois que je crois qu'il y a
vraiment rien à faire avec moi à la
salsa ça
ne m'aime pas
voilà là ça ça ne m'aime pas et quand
j'étais parti en Argentine c'était le
tango et Tango j'en parle même pas mais
bon
c'est dommage d'avoir perdu nos défis
oui
[Musique]
qui est revenu allez on ira voir un peu
ce qui se passe à ton on refera un petit
tour des stades
après après c'est un magasin et donc on
ira voir un peu tout le monde et puis
c'est vrai que je sais pas si vous savez
lire le titre mais on suit aussi en
priorité entre Français à les
redafirouzes bien sûr les joueurs qui
jouent le gain du tournoi comme Naka et
carvana
on regarde tout le monde
c'est des parties
plus bien sûr la joue au 40e coup mais
on va pas rester 4 heures sur la même
partie on est là pour pour tout regarder
dans l'évolution du tournoi tous nos
intérêts
[Musique]
je pense que ça a pas pris l'avantage
malgré les blancs et on arrive dans une
finale où
ça semble compliqué de gagner pour les
blancs on va voir comment ça tricote
C4 de
Wesley qui permet de fixer un petit peu
les pions sur case noir et de limiter un
petit peu le fond en V6 tu vois il y a
un problème quand même sur le pur C5 et
du coup maintenant le fou et voilà donc
en pratique ça peut toujours poser
problème c'est une activité du roi etc
bon c'est intéressant prise donc là les
blancs et c'est passé le roi mais
malheureusement pour les blancs les
noirs sont trop actifs en fait ça
suffira pas
le roi en dessin qui avant effectivement
ça aurait été un petit peu différent là
comment on passe
je pense que ça va faire bon ça va faire
du fascinant pas du tout mon cache ce
plan P ici pas tout
je te l'accorde
répétitions
[Musique]
il a rien à perdre en fait il a
absolument rien à perdre saut donc
on est au 32e
une seconde d'increment c'est très très
peur c'est quasi rien c'est à peine si
on a le temps d'appuyer sur la pendule
pendant une seconde
on a vu il y en a plusieurs qui sont qui
sont tombés en Armageddon
on a vu qui est tombé je crois deux fois
deux fois
quand
il a perdu encore
[Musique]
je l'ai vu je l'ai vu mais je me suis en
plus
[Musique]
je pense qu'il peut la gagner
je pense qu'il y a un monde où il a
gagné
aussi
[Musique]
à 4 quand ça tourne ça tourne pas mal
à six on attend
un peu difficile effectivement mais bon
il n'a pas le droit de vivre
donc en fait même quand tu joues pas
bien tu te retrouves encore un monstre
derrière
[Musique]
c'est la seule partie qui est terminée
le meilleur mondiaux donc forcément
que des énormes parties
et salut à toi la Licorne
[Musique]
merci d'être passé en tout cas
et si un jour je besoin de cours à faire
ça
[Musique]
il va venir ici il est bon
qui contrôle toutes les cases noires
c'est par tous les moyens de trouver un
peut-être par-ci par là peut-être la
foule 5 c'est un coup malin
pour éviter ça et vraiment dominer
le cavalier
te chercher le pion en 4 avec les noirs
[Musique]
mais en terme de stratégie de partie
j'ai envie de te dire je vois pas
l'intérêt
de défense marche bien a besoin d'aller
chercher
pour faire nul quoi si tu fais nul tu
gagnes la partie donc si la défense
marche bien t'as pas besoin
d'aller à tout prix manger
oui tu vas tu vas prendre un risque mais
là tu as pas besoin de prendre le risque
si ça marche bien
tu vois quand on s'en fout des 6 ça fait
nul tu vas pas chercher plus
[Musique]
donc peut-être qu'il essaie quand même
alors
ça va
il prend le risque
c'est jeune incroyable
un coup de
[Musique]
si tu vas créer comme ça à ton petit
pion passé
tu mets en danger
tu t'obliges les blancs à
bah eux ne pas attaquer
en fait si tu feras un petit peu passive
ou si tu es obligé à défendre ou alors
c'est tout bénef c'est pas grave
[Musique]
pas tout défendre sur ça j'ai ça et sur
ça j'ai ça ma tenue
voir on fait un petit tour rapidement et
salut Ruth
salut les routes
alors Carlsen toujours sa position de
travail où il a sa paire de fou il a
deux contrats maintenant il a réussi à
changer des pions h et il va sûrement à
un moment donné finir par pousser P4 et
essayer de de
faire valoir sa paire de fou vous êtes
la paire de fou et ben
par défaut on va essayer d'ouvrir la
position et c'est ce que carcène essaie
de nous faire ici
ouais merci à toi en tout cas ça fait
très plaisir ouais alors on part sur un
cas maintenant allez on part surnaka
Naka qui qui a tout cette position qui
est complètement gagnante je crois en
retard était où va-t-on on s'est arrêté
à tour des cinq je crois
oui on s'attendait peut-être à Tours
c'est de T4 il a réussi à finalement à
rendre ce pion pour ouvrir la position
A5
et écoute les deux pions sont toujours
ici est-ce que dégâts
des quatre
je te dis bon écoute je pousse mes pions
j'adoption de plus mais bon il y a la
paire de fou les cases blanches c'est
vrai que ça fait un petit peu peur F4 il
faut F5 ça peut faire un petit peu peur
au niveau du contre-jeu tu vois même et
même comme G5 G4 pour aller attaquer un
petit peu le pion des 4 aussi assimiler
salut
tu étais à au top top 16 je t'ai vu
jouer quelques jours
mais bon si jamais j'arrive vraiment à
changer des pièces et à bien jouer
solide enfin D4 cavaliers 5 bien blindé
la position ça peut être pas mal
j'ai vu là-bas enfin j'ai pas vu la
partie j'ai très très vite j'ai pas eu
ton analyser mais j'ai vu que c'était
chaud chaud et bon ça se passe très bien
la prochaine fois
l'an prochain
j'y étais en Top 12 et quelques années
c'est pas mal passé j'ai fait deux
points
sur 8 je crois
une victoire et de nuls et
et
mais après j'avais une moyenne îlot à
2550 je crois
[Musique]
je pense que ton équipe finira devant
celle de stouffe les paris sont lancés
ne me dis pas que tu vas signer à
Bischwiller
on a de on a de grands
de grande ambition pour l'année
prochaine
ah oui
c'est quand même une des meilleures
équipes de championnats avec Bischwiller
c'est déjà bien si on arrive à se mettre
à faire
tu fais un tournoi tous les meilleurs
joueurs de France du monde c'est génial
c'est juste trop bien aussi les
interclubs à l'année
des petits moments comme ça c'est vrai
que nous on a une équipe de potes et
qu'en fait nous ça nous permet de se
voir un week-end par mois donc ça reste
cool
après après
tu pars 10 jours avec
avec ton équipe tu loues un super grand
lit c'est les vacances un peu mais que
je suis échec en vrai c'est aussi
quelque chose c'est intéressant et par
rapport au niveau ça fait que nous à
chaque fois en N1 on a une très très
bonne équipe
pour la N1 et
et il y a pas mal de matchs c'est vrai
que des fois on joue contre des joueurs
qui sont quand même beaucoup moins fort
que nous
il y a plusieurs matchs pour la montée
bien sûr à peu près généralement mais
tout le reste généralement on est censé
gagner les matchs assez largement et
c'est vrai que bon on a tout envie de le
prendre des grands quoi tu vois c'est
motivant quand tu joues un match
contre je sais pas 2005 2006 tout le
temps c'est enfin je trouve que c'est
motivant et en plus moi ça me force à
travailler à me préparer à être hyper
focus c'est sûr quand tu vois dans les
poches et puis là les 10 jours faire un
temps en terme de
chaque un petit peu comme des
championnats de France mais tu
y vas t'as presque pas le droit à
l'erreur après ce qui est bien c'est que
là tu joues pour une équipe aussi tu as
tes copains pour te motiver
en plus moi je pense que j'ai les motos
travaillé les échecs que quand j'attends
ta bouche par exemple
on répertoire
bon après je veux pas bien mais bon ça
c'est autre chose je faisais des
mauvaises parties mais
en fait c'est une expérience
joueur il fait une compétition ou à côté
de toi tu as un VL quoi tu vois ce que
je veux dire enfin c'est juste c'est ouf
je trouve ça ouf quoi
ça mélange amateur par formateur et
professionnel
donc c'est juste une expérience
géniale je suis hyper content d'avoir
réussi à monter et puis et puis et puis
voilà quoi
j'espère que
tu vas te maintenir ouais bon on va se
faire plaisir surtout et on verra bien
mais bien sûr on va essayer de se
maintenir on va essayer de bâtir au chat
enfin voilà on va essayer de
faire tout ça quoi
donc voilà allez on va voir un peu ce
que tout ce qui se passe chez anis
Pascal un peu ce qu'on m'avait dit on
avait parlé à un moment donné un
sacrifice de pion pour activer
pour activer
[Musique]
par B la liste de d'ouvrir comme ça
un petit peu genre
tu veux ouvrir ta position et c'est moi
je trouve que c'est ça c'est un coup qui
est logique dans l'idée de virer ce fou
et essayer de sortir celui-là mais de
l'autre côté tu donnes des pions et ça
par contre c'est un coup qui est
difficile à faire parce qu'en fait quand
tu manges là puis on isolé est encore
plein de trous sur case noire donc c'est
quand même un coup difficile à faire
tu sors pas non plus de des problèmes en
un coup
trois B5 dames des 5 et d'un procédé
imaginez dans les 5 c'est la partie est
un point à deux donc il y a pas de champ
de plus en fait peut-être que si on
reprend des 7 pas tout est-ce que c'est
possible je crois que oui ah non pardon
[Musique]
aussi ça marche pas du tout
par contre
en DS7 à l'air intéressant dans le sens
où si tu défends c'est pas admettons
comme ça
je crois que j'arrête de commenter pas
tous dit n'importe quoi
mais voilà donc quand on en que
le reposait c'est très important de
jouer sur sa propre couleur de fou et
de jouer très actif
activement et mettre la pression donc là
fous d'écart par exemple est vite taper
sur G7 pour être ici une belle idée
pendant que les Noirs avaient essayé de
vite je veux quelque chose j'allais dire
tomber si je fais vite mettre le fou en
B7 et essayer de de faire des menaces et
activer ce je pense que les Noirs
paieraient très très cher pour voir ce
petit point scepticisme
et je crois pas qu'il payerait le prix
d'une tour quand même mais
pas mal de notes
c'est ça qui est important dans ce
tournoi
et moi je reste sur mon truc j'avais dit
que Gerry allait gagner
pour l'instant il garde quand même pas
mal de chance j'ai misé la nuit
de partout quasiment donc
[Musique]
parce qu'il avait une superposition
jusqu'à avoir pris le plan B2 juste ici
là
il aurait pu tranquillement manger F7 et
avoir une finale qui était avantageuse
et au lieu de ça et ben il a mangé B2 il
a donné des six et du coup la position
avec le fou qui maintenant était mauvais
derrière la structure d'option c'est
vous qui va s'ouvrir parce que depuis en
D il va pouvoir un jour sortir de là
avec les blancs en dessin et un fou qui
va être actif donc c'est pour ça que la
jauge est tout en haut parce que
elle a du mal juger quelque chose c'est
un tour à deux avec tes jouets la chose
qui redescend on avait dit fou à deux je
crois alors on avait dit un truc comme
ça pour essayer de faire valoir
partout à deux
on avait montré plutôt
à deux cavaliers à 4 tours
H7 et tours mais j'en fais des pièces et
ce cavalier il est hyper embêtant quoi
il faut que j'arrive à le sortir de là
mais dans l'autre côté comment est-ce
que après tout tour ici et elle est là
comment il sort ce cavalier
[Musique]
donc
ouais position
position qui est dur pour le français
pour aller raisin ici
la raison c'est caractère qui allait
dans le chat le carton est encore à
gagner non pas encore
pas la gagner ah oui en plus ouais pour
Magnus mais bon encore une fois qu'on
n'est pas en forme mais toujours contre
les livres mondiales c'est toujours
difficile
il a un peu en plus mais bon en fait
et je vous rappelle après tout regarde
il ne peut pas jouer ou au sein parce
qu'il y aurait une petite tactique avec
tout reprend ici et
un clouage je ne peux pas récupérer la
tour je n'ai pas le droit il y aura
échec
bon ça ça va pas arriver à Magnus il va
pas perdre cette position ne vous
inquiétez pas
généralement non
en fait on utilise l'ordinateur environ
5 minutes par jour à peu près
pour te pour te dire
pour te dire un petit peu les choses
parce que
s'appuie sur la jauge beaucoup pour
essayer de on a quand même la jauge qui
nous permet de dire bah parce que là il
y a il y a un gars loupé ou non de voir
de nous aider à trouver des coups mais
sinon sinon on sent pas on se passe des
coups précis de l'ordinateur on fait
signer un petit peu nos cerveaux après
tu sais qu'il y en a certains aussi dans
le chat qui regarde un petit peu
l'ordinateur au fur et à mesure même
nous aussi des fois il y a des positions
très concrètes en fatigue un peu donc
mais de manière générale on met
quasiment jamais l'ordinateur
on aime bien
calculer par nous-mêmes et aussi vous
livrer une évaluation qui est humaine
parce que c'est bien facile de lire un
ordinateur mais en fait
n'importe qui peut le faire ça vous
mettre n'importe qui sur un stream qui
va vous lire les coûts de l'ordinateur
et ben ils vont ils vont réussir quoi
mais nous on essaie de vous expliquer un
peu par logique
ce qui se passe et
vous expliquer un petit peu les coups
aussi ce que nous on pense de la
position
extrêmement compliquée aussi pour pour
justement par rapport à partir sur des à
partir de
de principes qu'on connaît et d'idées
qu'on comprend pour pour pouvoir les
expliquer plutôt que de donner juste les
meilleures variantes et on le voit en
plusieurs fois notamment les parties
dans les raisins ils jouent pas
forcément ce qu'on pense et il est très
surprenant dans ses coups depuis trouver
des idées que nous on voit pas
après nous on n'a pas le niveau des
joueurs qui jouont on n'est pas à 2700
et de l'eau donc un autre un autre
humble au niveau on vous explique un
petit peu ce qu'on pense d'écoute la
position tout ça
je pense que c'est généralement apprécié
un autre niveau on vous montre un peu ce
que nous on pense des fois on se plante
complètement
rien de surtout bah ouais non mais des
fois on se on se plante complètement des
fois on rate des choses des fois on
donne des personnes un coup tout à
l'heure je vais donner trois pièces en
trois coups tu as vu la partie
mais bon on est comme ça enfin un moment
donné
[Musique]
ça c'est en termes de ça fait trois
heures
en fait il y a plein de gens qui
commandent des tournois sur plein de
trucs des gens qui sont focus sur
l'analyse de l'ordinateur et du coup ils
se prennent pas la tête du tout ils font
ça et puis voilà pourquoi pas moi je dis
pas mais je pense que vous vous préférez
qu'on amène un truc par logique en
expliquant ce que nous on pense des
parties des structures tout ça plutôt
que de lire bêtement un
moteur d'analyse que absolument tout le
monde peut lire et pas forcément dire
comprendre voilà
donc bon dans tous les cas nous on
préfère être comme ça ça nous permet
aussi à nous de travailler enfin de
rentrer dedans et de vraiment essayer de
comprendre et aussi de passer avec vous
généralement entre 4 et 5 heures par
jour
comme j'ai ces événements et en faisant
quelque chose on travaille et je pense
que l'autre jour j'en parle avec Fatou
et je disais à Patou que je pense que
même moi le fait de commenter sur
tiascom enfin ça me fait vachement
penser déjà
que je connais pas forcément les
structures que je connais pas forcément
je passe quatre ou cinq heures par jour
à calculer dans plein de pollution dans
plein de trucs au final ça me force à
fournir un travail ça me force à
travailler ça me force à calculer et
dans mes journées
un peu tous les jours je ne fournis pas
ce travail parce que bah voilà
simplement je sais pas
mais ça me force un peu à progresser
[Musique]
les échecs faut y passer du temps quoi
qu'on fasse que ce soit pour jouer
travailler étudier enfin quel que soit
la manière de travailler les échecs il
faut y passer du temps et là en
commentant et en réfléchissant sur
différentes positions bah on passe du
temps on fait on peut signer nos cerveau
comme j'ai dit et bah et ça fait du bien
ça fait du bien pour progresser surtout
qui est revenu au professionnel
aussi c'est
je suis contente et l'arméedon après pas
de tirage au sort supplémentaire
je pense que c'est bien comme ça
on aurait été bien
toujours deux pions de plus pour ma
carte et il y a de moins en moins de
jeux enfin tout je crois que là
pour ce 5 bon on va écouter si vous
voulez ce que vous dit à car
alors j'ai plein de points ouh là la
Patou tu vas être contente
10 minutes de la carte c'est ça j'ai
deux vidéos de maca c'est pas vrai ils
sont arrivés à l'instant
j'ai deux vidéos de maca et j'ai une de
quarantaine et une de Wesley mais bon je
vais surtout aller sur Naka
en norvégien donc je vais changer de
d'anglais
tout ça
déjà
et si oui on peut aller voir ça
rapidement ça me fait une petite pause
on reste là mais je veux dire
[Musique]
il y a un deck non qui va arriver d'ici
un quart d'heure à peu près
donc pour l'instant on n'est pas encore
en direct les gens ont encore quand même
pas mal de temps
devant eux et du coup c'est intéressant
juste avant le diagnotte de de voir un
peu tout ça pas tout on y va
c'est pas la bonne je vous mets la vraie
voilà la numéro 4
5 après c'est fini donc il en profite et
vu la taille du truc je dirais que c'est
des vidéos
ils font à peu près deux minutes ou une
minute 30 minutes je pense vu la taille
du fichier
Hikaru gagne le tournoi Patou route
pardon si il bat carvana avec les blancs
dans la position qu'il a juste ici là il
est bien c'est parti pour la vidéo et je
vous dis à tout de suite
musique
[Musique]
de plus en plus optimiste sur ce genre
de gagner la partie et il a pas dit
qu'il était gagnant mais quasiment voilà
donc je pense qu'il va gagner et si vous
voulez je vous remets
la dernière vidéo
qui vient de nous faire à tout de suite
[Musique]
de retour
donc pareil il a donné des variantes il
disait que il a il a pensé à plein de
choses
qu'il aurait pu autoriser mais vous
savez quand on est gagnant et ben il
faut tout faire sauf de l'eau du
contrôleur et il a vraiment dit qu'il
voulait pas donner une
une once de contre jeu à son adversaire
aucun contre jeu et il veut gagner la
partie tranquillement il dit que si
Fabien trouve une défense quelque chose
concret et ben
voilà mais il pense que ça n'existe pas
et il pense que il va gagner la partie
qui va rien et que il est extrêmement
en confiance dans cette partie pour la
gagner et ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il
a dit en tout cas je reviendrai plus
tard pour vous redire donc du coup
on l'attend
on l'attend d'avoir confiance
il est quand même revenu après il a dit
qu'il avait beaucoup réfléchi son
content d'un coup ce qui est vraiment
être sûr que c'était bien le bon coup il
fait attention il joue pas tempo et tu
sens qu'il a un poil nerveux quand même
mais
il est perdu son avance
[Musique]
au temps
et puis
tout simplement il essaie de de
continuer normalement et de gagner la
partie
manger les pions
pas claire si ça emprise il faut quand
même finir en même temps
si je fais ça plus tard ce pion pourrait
être emprise donc c'est pas forcément
génial
parce qu'elle va laisser 3 simple solide
ferme la colonne garde le pion à deux
mais autorise ou 1 F3 qui est peut-être
une bonne nouvelle peut-être pas ça
échange des pièces ça me casse un peu ma
structure
pas clair
et si je perds à deux peut-être que plus
tard je pourrai pas
5 peut-être que je peux mettre la
pression sur G7 il y a plein de coupes
possibilités il va regarder il va
essayer de
tout simplement de jouer au plus simple
il va essayer de vraiment de donner
aucun contrôle de l'adversaire habite
qui va se battre tout ce qui peut pour
ne pas perdre cette partie une partie
assez compliquée quand même
très compliqué
dans trois minutes
d'ailleurs on n'a pas on a fait petit
truc de mal nul
ion
ou pas
essayer de voir
peut-être un jour
c'est pas grave d'ailleurs ça vient
d'être signé la nul je suis
[Musique]
m3
je sais pas tu parles norvégien
norvégien
c'est sûr que non
par contre
est-ce que
crowdan sur le chat éventuellement c'est
gros âne sur le chat ça peut ça peut
nous aider qui nous a un petit peu
traduit la dernière fois
je pense qu'il est pas là il faut qu'il
travaille quand même
pas je crois pas vécu là-bas d'ailleurs
où je me trompe
mais
[Musique]
oui en russe russe je sais à peu près
mais norvégien non
norvégien important pour ton amour pour
ton amour pour Magnus tu aurais pu faire
un effort quand même d'apprendre un peu
le Norvégien en vrai je suis un peu déçu
je suis un peu déçu quelques mois après
ça me dit un truc
assez lointain tout ça pour moi aussi ça
a été signé un Magnus Abdou nul c'est
signé et on va voir la magret de ces
quelques instants on va on va on va
recevoir
on va recevoir bientôt une
une hop un message sur slack pour nous
avertir de l'heure à laquelle ça va
jouer
donc
pas se tromper
comment défendre ma
cavalier pour faire du taux d'accord
mais il y a toujours pas mal parce que
on a un petit projet qui va reprendre et
qui va laisser notre voix sortir
on n'aime pas forcément par contre les
Blancs ont toujours leurs deux pieds en
avance dont un pion passé
donc les échanges ne nous dérange pas
forcément après faut pas
faut pas échanger en dégradant beaucoup
sa position
mais si on échange on a quand même deux
pions de plus et
ça sent la victoire
ça m'a l'air très dur là pour
Kawana je pense que c'est assez simple
bah alors niveau ça devrait après au
niveau du temps aussi pouvoir ce que ça
donne
est-ce que tu veux pousser des tout de
suite
parce qu'en fait si tu manges pas mon
cavalier et ben écoute je fais cavalier
des 4 et je prends F5 et je me laisse
ton décès d'attaque là bref c'est pas
mal de jeux et là H4 vu que la menace
c'est ça parce qu'il y a plus de couloir
du coup et ben tu vas te forcer à
prendre la décision est-ce que tu veux
manger ou pas manger comme tu l'as dit
ça casse la structure
ça échange les pièces ce qui m'arrange
aussi donc dans les deux cas je suis
content et en fait sa structure c'est
pas grave de l'avoir cassé parce que de
toute façon je n'ai pas Adam ce côté là
bas et trois pions contre trois camps
comme ça ça passe jamais tu pourras
jamais passer en fait tu vois les plus
on doubler je crois qu'on l'avait vu ce
thème avec Yo ça d'ailleurs quand on
était en stream l'autre jour et on
disait que les pions peuvent pas passer
parce que quand tu te crées un pion ben
je mange toujours un derrière en fait ça
passe jamais donc
je pense que c'est juste assez facile
est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour rapide
aussi
préciser H4 qui est ce qui est sympa tu
parlais de mettre un cavalier en T4 pour
aller taper le petit pion F ça nous
laisse aussi des possibilités peut-être
de faire H5 et
de pas laisser si facilement les les
Noirs se
défendre même si bien sûr je suis pas
possible tout de suite
ok F4 alors je comprends pas
je comprends pas trop l'idée
mais j'ai du mal à comprendre l'idée moi
j'ai envie de faire certaines potes
mais je sais pas j'ai envie de dire bah
je fais pareil je m'en fous je fais ça
ça 20h45 Carlson Abdou ok je note
ok on va faire un petit tour ou pas
c'est une partie très très chaude guéri
a réussi mettre son coup sur la super
casse des quatre pendant que
oui
et quand je mange là j'aurai un pion de
plus avec les Blancs et toujours c'était
un petit peu l'espoir des des Noirs
quand même
un jeu actif du style roi H7 pour rester
sur case blanche
avec l'idée que je continue peut-être
faire des 5 moi je vais sortir mon fond
en fait j'en ai marre ça y est genre
dessin
tout le temps qui arrive
et je sais pas là je peux défendre et
attaquer mais tu sens que il peut
espérer des choses
[Musique]
alors je pensais toujours
mais je sais pas si c'est bon
ça a l'air pas mal bonjour
intéressant pour sortir mais au final la
lettre aussi pour cette
on n'est pas encore sorti de ce problème
voilà dame 4 essayer de faire une menace
là
je vois pas du tout j'ai toujours
j'arrive pas à me défendre c'est dur
mais il y a des petits trucs qui
traînent donc
j'ai beaucoup de mal en fait à cause de
fou qui emprise j'arrive pas à activer
les pièces
ça m'a l'air trop dur
[Musique]
er
ça en place mais ok bon on va voir mais
bon
il fait vraiment une super partie là le
thème de la partie c'est
bon que le reposer bien sûr mais de base
c'était joué contre le foulard certains
bouger depuis le début
il n'a pas réussi à bouger ce coup
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
a priori madame reviens quoi
pas genre je fais un coup
un moment quand même madame
il y a beaucoup trop de choses qui ça ne
marche jamais ok rapidement ce qu'on va
voir notre
frenchy là qui a l'impression qu'il
ça se passe mal une pièce de moi ou une
pièce de moi que s'est-il passé
un pour ces deux qui va essayer 5 ou à
deux et là je vais carrément tout ce
qu'on avait dit après la prise la tour
qui rentre le cavalier qui vient ici
T6
c'est une horreur
et la prise ici sur le foot et enfermé
et
écoute bah
parmi je vais manger là en plus et tout
ça à cause de
[Musique]
ce qu'il a laissé
un peu trop ambitieux dans cette partie
avant
il a une meilleure finale avec les Noirs
envoyer le Fou est une très mauvais
derrière la structure qui avait la pas
de case donc ici tu as quand même
c'est 5 pour rentrer sur C4 pour rentrer
un peu par là-bas tu peux faire aussi
cavalier F6 tu as plein de coups et tu
as une position qui n'est jamais moins
bonne avec les noirs
et au lieu de faire ça il a fait en B2
et là il a commencé à voir tout en l'air
et qu'avait le premier c'est très mal
joué pour plusieurs raisons
j'attaquement bah je mange des sites etc
et même en plus de manière un peu
positionnelle vous voyez que en mangeant
des 6 et ben je me crée un peu passé
protégé et en plus et ben j'ouvre ce fou
qui était très très mauvais à des
misérable en se fout en B1 devient très
fort parce qu'on sait qu'on va réussir
plus tard à bouger le pion donc le fou
B1 après qu'elle va le prendre ici il
prend énormément de valeur
il passe de pourri à fort
et en plus j'ai un pion c'est très fort
donc là c'est pas si la vue s'il a buggé
s'il a sous-estimé ou c'est juste qu'il
a pas compris mais là c'était le gros
moment qui a fait perdre la partie à
l'IRESA là il est complètement perdu il
a une pièce de 2 mois il va juste
pousser le pion et c'est terminé propose
qu'on allait voir la partie de maca
c'est la partie la plus mouvementée en
tout cas la partie la plus importante
qui a réussi à mettre la cavalière le 5
comment il a fait pour virer la tour il
a fait tourner 4 waouh qui force ça quoi
parce que j'ai 5 je prends et je prends
deux fois
là je vais manger un troisième pion
quand même et après tout refuge
écoute j'ai envie de dire que que ma
bille il va abandonner très bientôt je
comprends qu'ils se sont un guerrier il
veut se battre il veut créer des choses
il peut perdre cette partie qui sera
synonyme de de bien le tournoi pour pour
Nakamura
sa première place qui a tenu si
longtemps
ça fait un petit peu mal pour carvana
auteur d'un énorme tournoi carvana mais
après Nakamura non plus et
[Musique]
il revient 3 ça va répéter bien
évidemment
pas répéter il veut gagner la partie
ainsi s'il y en a parti il gagne le
tournoi il faut qu'il gagne la partie
avec une nul une nulle en cette partie
fait gagner le tournoi à Fabi avec les
noirs
donc on pense que c'est Nakamura qui va
gagner Alicia il est plus actif il a
deux pions d'avance depuis le début de
la partie il domine il est aussi 5
minutes d'avance dans le temps alors que
cette note arrive
je pense qu'à moins
d'un tour de magie de carwana
je pense que va gagner la partie et le
tournoi
[Musique]
un coup je perds toute crédibilité au
niveau de la jauge désolé
la prochaine fois est-ce que ça
et on veut échanger on fait l'un ou
l'autre ça nous arrange
pas d'accord
savent
et
je suis d'accord que abandonner enfin
c'est pas un abandonnant qu'on peut
gagner une partie ça c'est clair mais
après ils savent qu'ils sont les limites
et des fois c'est aussi un peu par
respect tu peux abandonner les parties
parce que quand tu es complètement
perdant tu vas pas continuer une partie
avec 10 pièces de bois
aussi et donc là bien sûr il va se
battre il veut pas perdre qui va tourner
toutes les solutions et si vraiment il
considère que c'est perdant est vraiment
perdant perdant perdant il va pas
continuer jusqu'au maths il va pas c'est
perdre autant voilà ça va être un moment
donné il va dire bon ok bravo quoi juste
un mieux que moi etc c'est normal de
continuer et
que ce soit à ce niveau là mais à tous
niveaux et pas trop faire confiance à
son adversaire
pas que quand il y a des réseaux de
pattes qui qui se profilent on est là
pour ça il faut jouer il faut jouer
c'est le seul c'est la seule façon de
pas perdre mais effectivement
un moment donné il faut aussi savoir bah
savoir abandonner si on a si on y croit
plus nous même en fait il faut
abandonner à partir du moment où tu
crois plus du tout
ça sert à rien de continuer si tu sais
que tu dans tous les cas tu vas perdre
au moins de espoir et là il y a aussi le
truc que c'est la là la partie du titre
il était en tête donc ça ça fait sens
quelque part de continuer un petit peu
aussi quand tu vois des des gens qui
sont gagnants toute la partie
tu as du mal tu passes perdant d'un seul
coup
toi tu as du mal à abandonner parce que
c'est dans la logique aussi de se dire
bah si je suis arrivée jusque là il faut
que je continue au moins un petit peu
voir ce que ça donne et bah là il a
trois continents encore un petit peu
mais
on va voir jusqu'à quand jusqu'à où
après aussi au niveau du temps
c'est un petit peu logique de continuer
mais forcément si il est mort ils vont
pas aller jusqu'au matin s'il y a un
match forcé
donc là ils ont plus qu'un seul coup à
faire un seul coup à faire pour arriver
au 40e couple
donc voilà là ils ont vu une minute et 9
minutes 10 secondes par coup donc c'est
ça se termine en rapide en blitz et Anna
complètement gagnant donc mais après il
croyait jusqu'au bout il faut il faut
essayer de trouver au dernier moment des
complications
mais il faut savoir en fait que
à ce niveau là les jours tellement fort
il ne te laisse pas revenir quand tu es
foutu ils vont pas laisser une dame ou
un matin un coup ou voilà c'est genre
très expérimenté c'est les meilleurs
joueurs du monde et quand tu es perdant
mais vraiment on perdant pardon ça
abandonne donc là bien sûr c'est une
position qui qui est quasiment
abandonnable même peut-être abandonnable
en fait
de jouer parce que
il va essayer
si tu regardes
c'est beaucoup et puis il y a aussi le
l'activité un petit peu
qui manque chez les Noirs après le fait
aussi d'avoir un peu subi toute la
partie sans avoir eu du mal à
s'en sortir
des moments tu crois plus trop justement
tu as tellement galéré que tu dis bon si
j'ai pas réussi jusqu'en final à
faire quelque chose j'ai peut-être pas
réussir d'un seul coup
si je prends là attention échec
et mat
donc bon en tout cas elle est comme ça
et surtout comprendre
il essaie de tenter des réseaux tenter
des choses un petit peu tout ce qui peut
mais au top 10 mondial
je crois que tu auras du mal à te
laisser berner
c'est que sur cavalier prend à 5 et
avoir échec d'abord il est simple pour
mon assistant et quand tu manges là et
ben maintenant j'ai
point F3 voilà il a raison
il mange il y a plus de problème
trop de trucs
donc il y a rien du tout
[Musique]
qui sont possibles même pour là je pense
que tout se joue après tant qu'à faire
quand c'est gratuitement
je vais te dire
[Musique]
moi je crois que je me priverais pas en
fait
les choses
[Musique]
en fait
je crois que je préfère ça
j'ai trop de option quoi
[Musique]
on regarde plus
parce que
c'est vraiment de laisser aucune chance
à l'adversaire
malheureusement
en tant que les pièces l'Armageddon
excuse-moi
un magasin où est-ce qu'on reste sur
celle-là
c'est vous qui choisissez
l'Air quand même perdu pour caravane
si vous voyez ce qu'on peut faire c'est
qu'on part sur la sur la vue pour Magnus
et que je vous mette un échiquier ah non
je peux pas mettre non je peux pas non
je peux pas mettre un seul
j'ai rien dit
personne personne pour aller voir karsen
je crois qu'ils veulent rester là
bas
juste pour vous embêter un peu on a
cette cette vue qui est assez sympa
quand même entre les deux joueurs on a
la partie et la vue et du coup c'est
plus simple en fait si vous voulez
revenir sur celle-là c'est pas grave on
revient sur celle là
sur le petit échiquier mais après les
gens vont pas forcément comprendre ce
qui se passe chez Magnus
on peut aller voir la partie de Magnus
et à côté on met
la partie de carbonara contre
un mix
sur 45 Abdou c'est quand même pas mal
aussi
donc ça on voit les deux
donc la partie qu'on voit qu'on voit en
dessous c'est la partie de NACA et par
contre là la partie là haut je vais
essayer de vous
la commenter un petit peu en carton qui
a 5 8 23 qu'elle est blanc Magnus qui a
gagné je crois pas tout ces armagasons
il est très fort en Armageddon
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 ma news qui a encore la
part de fou pour te faire des cavaliers
et là il peut manger un pion s'il mange
de pion en 16x
il ne mange pas F5 Magnus qui est je
pense à un très gros avantage un ancien
blues le voit gagner
[Musique]
tous les jours c'est parti
j'ai pas compris ce que tu as dit
il vient de perdre des quatre Magnus je
sais pas si vous avez vu un gros un gros
nom de la tête on se demande s'il a
peut-être juste blender le plan des
quatre Magnus
un excellent bluffeur
aujourd'hui que il avait travaillé cette
position contre
[Musique]
et qui souvenait plus souvenait plus la
prépa
Ré
il suffit de faire nul pour remporter la
Armageddon pour faire mieux le côté noir
il est bien parti
une minute
c'est pas énorme
et c'est vrai que la partie c'est du
chaos jusqu'au 40e coups
on est en malheureusement je peux pas la
suivre parce que j'essaye de maca en bas
c'est le pop type
c'est le pauvre type
et Naka qui fait la serrure
il attaque le cavalier il propose un
échange de cavaliers alors qu'il aurait
pu une caméra aller manger le pion à 5
elle dit non moi je veux le solide sur
Caval et B4 qui va être le coup enfin
tout je pense qu'on va avoir droit un
coup comme tour des 7 pour venir ici
avec le cavalier qui peut venir en F5 et
la pousser aussi
je pense qu'ici on va devoir garder les
pièces avec
car wanna ce qui est difficile
c'est la vie
et ma muscle qui donne une pièce encore
une fois utile et tout ça là il donne
pas de pièces il va te voir il va devoir
[Musique]
se séparer de sa part de fou
content il est pas content il voit qu'il
va manger là il va manger
jouer encore
mais
ce qui mangeait
de l'argent quand même quitte à la
perdre
même il avait un peu moins mais il avait
quand même
la paire de fou
et avec le coup qu'il a fait il a laissé
Abdou venir lui prendre la barre de flou
il a combattant blender c'est plusieurs
blender dans la même partie manuscrit
qui est très fatiguée ça se voit
se voit dans ses coups
de noir est toujours
faible il met toujours sur case blanche
pour pas se faire manger
et le fou mais si c'est important chez
les Blancs parce qu'il contrôle bien la
case F2
donc je sais pas si vous voyez bien les
cas quand on parle comme ça on parle de
la partie de Mac du sein il y a pas les
coordonnées sur l'échiquier
malheureusement
[Musique]
il essaie vraiment de garder les pièces
et de créer des choses mais
carvana
donc qui reste plus qu'une minute je
sais pas quel coup ils sont j'imagine
que ma venue a un incrément maintenant
d'une seconde ils ont passé 40e coup sur
mon
et le pion a franchi la case de garde ce
qui veut dire que le fou ne peut plus
défendre le petit pion
tout à l'heure
est-ce que tu penses Fatou que
les noirs
pour défendre l'option
si je mets le roi ailleurs il y a
cavaliers prend
essayer de répéter comme ça
si le roi monter en haut là en E5 avait
une fourchette en tout cas entre roi fou
et les touristes sont rangées lapin et
manger de là il est obligé de perdre
donc
il a un peu là
c'est bon
parce qu'on peut
les blancs vont essayer de remettre le
coup soit
totalement imprenables en plus sur casse
blanche
donc franchement
[Musique]
très très vite
pendant que la caméra grind et la
cavalerie 8 peut être de la part de la
cas pour échanger
ces pièces
dès que je peux manger une pièce il faut
il faut échanger il a fait F4
Grimes ça va être dans 16 minutes la
magazine
le cavalier
donc il y a pas eu
parce que
tout simplement je participe à un
tournoi
Manu ce qui va être plague et ben voilà
du 16 au 18 juin en Espagne
et c'est un tournoi qui peut me
permettre de passer maître international
si je gagne mon petit point qui me
manque
les quelques secondes à la pendule
qui a tourné il a réussi à ramener une
tour en G7 il rigole
[Rires]
en tout cas peut-être que moi je me
dirais à ta place et surtout il le fait
quand il lui
c'est pas gagnant encore mais écoute
[Musique]
ça tous gagner cette position
ou à ton dessin
est coupé mais
attention parce que là la pièce et c'est
gagné pour MacBook il gagne le pionch
incroyable
c'est un petit peu
à la fin
une enfilade qui se passait mais je
pense que
c'est pas content il rigole rigole son
niveau de jeu c'est assez marrant de
voir ça
non il tombe ok ok les deux ont le
sourire ils savent qu'ils ont tous
n'importe quoi oh c'est
franchement c'est des beaux échecs dans
le sens où
les deux joueurs rigolent ça se passe
bien et ça apprécie et pour ça c'est
assez sympa en tout cas
avec laquelle tu es tombé
j'avoue c'est moche ouais c'est très
moche
allez alors du coup on va retourner sur
la partie de Nakamura c'est la partie
numéro 3
et voilà on a la vue ici avec la partie
anti-recte et Naka qui est toujours
toujours gagnant tout simplement donc on
aura à quelle heure exactement on aura
on aura guéri
ouais à gauche je pense que elle a
appris beaucoup de valeur elle a pris au
moins peut-être 1000% de sa valeur là
pas mais
21h15 à tous le départage entre Guiri et
ma média
cette fois je retiens pour le début
E
que les Noirs ont dans les faits mieux
réussi les Armageddon d'une pièce
je sais pas si
[Musique]
ça dépendait aussi des joueurs il y en a
qui préfèrent qui préfèrent jouer les
Noirs il y en a qui préfèrent jouer les
blancs ça dépend aussi du style de jeu
mais bon
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'ai que j'ai
vérifié politique
[Musique]
en direct on va avoir on a 10 minutes
avant avant de la dernière partie le
dernier Armageddon de
deux championnats d'ailleurs
donc c'est signé donc Naka champion Naka
champion du Nord-Ouest 2023 franchement
ils ont fait un truc assez monstrueux le
résultat chacun donc on peut vous
montrer si vous voulez un petit peu les
résultats les standings
enfin les résultats de la ronde en cours
vous avez encore anniv
dans 10 minutes mais à part ça vous avez
Ariane Tariq a batturosaro qui a battu
Fabienne
par les Blancs donc parlez-moi pardon
donc
et le classement est ici donc Nakamura
qui chipe la première place à karwana
vraiment sur la dernière partie donc
c'est d'ennemi 16 pour
Caravana et ici je suis très content de
vous dire que Google termine avec 14 et
demi 3e Google c'est le petit poucet
il a seulement 17 ans et
2740 kg 17 ans je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte il est presque dans le top
10 mondial maintenant grâce son tournoi
il termine quand même devant des stars
comme Wesley Sow anusa
ils vont peut-être tous les deux prendre
une place dans le classement
oui c'est vrai Camille
passe devant Pierrot c'est vrai et Kiri
guéri m'a
égal à asso mais s'il remportait un
magreton
passe devant
une place et ma média Rohff qui prend
déjà une pièce une place et qui peut
rattraper car l'ancienne aussi donc
ça fait quand même pas mal de place les
prix ça se joue en note
c'est plus qu'elle se voit les prix on
peut vous les alors non vous avez
cherché mais du coup bah je peux les je
peux les retrouver j'ai le lien qui doit
être par là Fatou je peux vous dire
pendant qu'on attend pendant qu'on
attend la
partie de attendez je vais chercher
partie de guéri qu'on va attendre avec
un patience
les prix ils sont ici et le gain du
tournoi donc c'est pour c'est pour ça
moi qui gagne 750 000 noces
alors pas tout faire
[Musique]
on a envie de dire que c'est énorme mais
est-ce que tu peux nous faire
moi je vais marquer 750 mille notes
et bonne soirée en euros bonne soirée
malin ça fait 104000 euros presque 65000
euros pour Nakamura ici
65e Nakamura et pendant car voilà qui
est quand même
perd sa partie il va quand même avoir
droit
à 34000 en fait il a quand même perdu
ouais
Caravana qui perd 34 sur la partie canon
30 000 euros en perdant contre un cas à
30000 euros ça commence à être pas mal
quand même mais bon
ils vont jouer l'Armageddon donc ce sera
seulement une fois que l'Armageddon sera
fini que les poissons ajoutés
tu vas prendre 21000 euros donc voilà
les prix c'est des prix énormes mais
encore une fois
si on compare ces prix là
un mode sport et Ben
et ben franchement c'est pas énorme
quand tu gagnes 65000 euros c'est énorme
65000 euros mais en fait regarde comme
un combien il prend Nadal pour gagner
Roland Garros
combien il prend Mbappé enfin voilà en
fait quand vous comparez les échecs
au niveau effectivement donc ça l'a pas
beaucoup comment à la fois ridicule
donc voilà après on a quand même content
de voir pourquoi tu vas me coûter en
plus il est encore tout nouveau dans le
circuit 20000 euros c'est quand même pas
mal tu vois c'est cool merci beaucoup
rkp pour ton commentaire aussi
[Musique]
développé
un tennis le foot etc c'est la vie c'est
comme ça
tu veux nous rendre riche moi je veux
bien
j'accepte aussi et
[Rires]
je prends et je me débrouille avec
t'inquiète pas
contre
ma média la prochaine partie qu'on va
avoir des 5 minutes les gens qui sont
pas installés
qui aura les blancs alors Fatou j'ai
reçu pendant qu'on parlait j'ai reçu
après la partie je vais voir je vais
voir si en quelle langue c'est
imagine
le début il a tout le temps de norvégien
mais je vais quand même regarder
l'humidité et ensuite je vous dirai par
la première fois c'est un camion qui a
décidé de
démarrer
un petit carillon aussi non tout à
l'heure
même le matin ça sonne ça me réveille le
matin incroyable quoi
alors attends une seconde
il est fatigué je vais vous le montrer
hein mais ça norvégien on va rien
comprendre ni par hasard quelqu'un parle
norvégien dans le chat et ben on sera
très content
de vous avoir avec nous pour commenter
voilà si un volontaire dans le chat
je vais vous mettre alors on comprend
rien ça dure pas très longtemps on
comprend rien mais on voit un peu le
body language de Magnus qui on va lui
fatiguer il rigole et il a envie que ça
se termine et il va rentrer à la maison
donc je vous montre je vous montre ça et
puis et puis après on va attaquer la
l'Armageddon de guérir
tout le monde
[Musique]
pour cette
voilà
compris mais on voit qu'il est fatigué
en tout cas on voit qu'il est fatigué
qu'il en peut plus mais Fatou j'ai reçu
aussi
une interview de
champion du jour et je pense que ça va
être très très long je vais juste voir
combien de temps à dur parce que
je vais je vais essayer de regarder
je vais regarder combien de temps elle
dure
il a parlé du
temps
il a gagné le tournoi il vient de battre
il vient de battre ici
Fabien kervano pour Fabien kervana
pardon pour s'abuser le le
Norvège on va partir sur celle de
carwana ensuite on partira sur la partie
de guéri et en continuera l'événement et
cette partie
ok alors winner
[Applaudissements]
ça a commencé on va repartir sur la
partie pendant qu'on va débriefer
rapidement sur ce qui s'est passé
pour la partie 1 de Guy rock c'est la
même partie qu'on a vu en plastique sauf
que là il a un peu changé il a amélioré
la même erreur
pour pas se faire enfermer le fou
non
entre la partie et en fait ce n'est plus
de la ligne et cette pompe
et ensuite il était contente etc
qui est très fatigué et ils m'ont
demandé si le fait d'avoir gagné le
tournoi il passe numéro etc est-ce que
ça donne envie ça te motive pour revenir
à la compétition et faire plus de
tournoi il a dit
bah oui bien sûr
un peu par-ci par là mais je ne change
pas ce que j'avais dit voilà il va prime
Rica pas YouTube etc et il va continuer
ce qu'il fait le mieux et bien sûr les
jours encore quelques tournois ici mais
il veut pas revenir à la compétition en
tant que joueur professionnel enfin pas
que ça quoi il veut garder sa carrière
de streamer et continuer tout ça voilà
voilà Fatou
il a pu être des fois un petit peu
difficile et des fois même imbubles mais
j'ai l'impression qu'avec le string etc
j'ai l'impression qu'il est vachement
amélioré en fait et maintenant je
retrouve assez sympathique
d'accord cette espèce de personnage un
peu trop trop sûr de soi tu vois qui
peut parfois tu as envie de lui dire bon
vas-y molo
mais c'est un personnage quoi et puis
l'anime la vue quand il anime le
confessionnal bah ça ça fait rire tout
le monde et ça
il veut clairement un rôle les gens ils
aiment ça
c'est marrant quoi
j'aime bien ça
en tout cas si je trouve ça amusant
donc là
qui rit il change toutes les pièces il
garde cette partie il gagne un McDon
et par contre si il n'arrive pas à
gagner la partie en cas d'égalité de nul
c'est mon erreur qui remportera la
margado donc là il y a un pion isolé
pour un média off et un fou qui
caractérisé on dit que c'est un mauvais
coup parce que le fou il a même couleur
que les pions du sang et des pions en
général donc ce que fait dirige pour
cette très très bien il échange des
pièces pour faire valoir son terme
cavalier qui est un meilleur duo que tu
as un fou
et en plus il va bloquer il va venir
bloquer alors moi je regarde T3 pour
venir policier attaquer là-bas et en
plus une fois que tu fais ça tu mets un
cavalier en E3 pour bloquer le pion qui
bloque à lui et essayer de te faufiler
un peu de partout et de grind je pense
qu'ici guéri a des gens raisonnable de
gagner la partie
échec d'un massette c'est une menace
bien sûr
qui va arriver en fait j'ai l'impression
que ça ça va faire
plein de trous sur case noir A4
interruption et c'est blindé sur casse
blanche et l'objectif de manière
processus
et maintenant ça te recommande des
fonctions
[Musique]
un petit pion c'est beaucoup en finale
après j'aurais peut-être pu essayer de
me venger sur un autre pion Jordan F6
pour attaquer pour attaquer là-bas
donc c'est
c'est passif quoi
moi je voudrais B3 pour empêcher Damas
de pour un jeu solide voilà c'est joué
tous défend en fait besoin de prendre
des risques à 5 pas mal aussi pour
bloquer les pions sur casse blanche et
plus tard aller peut-être aller piquer
les clignoter comme ça une fois que tu
joues à 5 les pions sont complètement
vissés qui pourra plus jamais avancer on
dirait de faire C4 qui est très très
bien aussi un tas de majorité tu pousses
tes pions
à 5
fixer un cavalier
par rapport
ne peut pas jouer
bah oui
va pouvoir jouer en fait c'est une
horreur en fait
sur une bonne note ce tournoi sur wechat
et ben s'il vient la partie dépasse tout
je crois c'est ça je peux regarder
rapidement je vais regarder je vais pas
vous mettre le placement devant les yeux
là vous avez mieux à faire mais
guéri qui a 11 ans il passe à 12h30 en
cas de victoire il passe à 13 il passe
devant saut mais il reste quand même
quatrième
donc
en note ça fait combien
ça fait combien
[Musique]
180 donc comment ça fait
combien
1700 euros de différence bon je pense
qu'ils sont en fait
moi je m'en fous pas mais je pense que
lui il s'en fout
à ce niveau là quand même ils sont pas
mis de près
[Musique]
aucun échec possible je pense que son
idée moi je reviens
ça y est oui
les noirs
jusqu'à petite manœuvre de dinde c'est
pour ça
encore une fois je baisse trop
facilement
et non moi j'aime bien le petit C5
mais j'imagine que tout à l'heure il
n'est pas ça parce que peut-être des
fois
je pense qu'il aime bien son cavalier
ici et qui voulait passer juste avec la
dame
mais ce que ça peut
passer
un petit peu
c'est pas encore évident il se regarde
comme ça et ce qui va enfin faire le
plan de tout avec ces cinq cavités
je vais bien avant l'idée de faire c'est
ça maintenant on aime bien
et même tenter pas mal aussi
à m'activer un peu là il faut jouer là
les jours on sent qu'ils sont fatigués
ils sont en fin de tournoi ça fait une
semaine qu'ils enchaînent les parties
lentes
tous les jours et c'est fatiguant en
fait c'est fatiguant donc l'énergie qui
m'aide dans ce tournoi dans la
préparation
c'est c'est vraiment très long donc des
fois c'est normal qu'en fait pendant
aussi c'est pas des erreurs histoire
moins performant ils ont plus lentement
c'est tout à fait normal
c'est normal de craquer
même si il craque encore pas beaucoup
hein par rapport
eux aussi d'ailleurs c'est un peu moins
c'est quand même plus fort que il craque
moins fort quoi mais il craque un peu
quand même il a fait plusieurs blondes
plus dégoûté quand il a lâché la paire
de fou que quand il a la sculpion
il perd la part de fou mais c'est la fin
du monde alors que nous c'est quoi une
paire de fou quoi
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
dans l'idée même l'idée de faire ces
cinq avec le plan B4 c'était le caméléon
de pousser etc et là maintenant un jour
tu aimes les idées avec dames bien celui
de à 6 et sur la prise faire ça tu vois
avec le roi on attaquer en 4
et on prépare
sur dame bien moi je vois bien un fou
c'est lui qui arrivait pour venir
défendre tout ça
plus une seconde parcours contre 2
minutes 45 avec une seconde parcours
qui a perdu deux fois autant dans un
magasin
[Musique]
dans la fuite pourquoi parce que je
défends là je défends là au cas où si
jamais il y a un problème d'échec
et en plus et ben je me lave cavaler ce
cadre pour venir en deux
très actif ouais mais en fait
on a un jouable donnez-moi ma glue s'il
vous plaît
demain a été joué
mais bon
un F6 c'est pas très beau tu as pas
envie de faire ça mais
par contre
on aimerait bien s'en débarrasser manger
de laisser tout ça
en perdant trois secondes tu vois
ils ont quand même
il va où le roi et chaque saint c'est
perdu non
plus tu as aucun échec possible à part
là peut-être échec échec tu peux essayer
ça en même temps
voilà juste il y a rien et ça va être
abandon je pense pas que tu l'auras même
pas un seul coup là
abandon et ça a été abandon et voilà
effectivement il y a plus d'échecs sur
dame là pour venir ici je peux échange
la dame et surprise je prends du pion ou
du cavalier c'est terminé l'option qui
va à dame donc cette partie d'Armageddon
et qui va piquer une place je crois
qu'il arrive quatrième dans ce tournoi
pour 20000nocks sur
où wesleau je vais vous montrer une
dernière fois et c'est très bien
résultat de la rendre regardez bien on a
un Magnus carte qui a perdu un
Armageddon le contrat Abdou où est-ce
que tu as perdu dans le magasin contre
bocage Makawa qui a battu la grosse
surprise qui a battu kerwana en partie
classique donc il est pique ça première
place du tournoi on a je guéri qui a
aussi battu à l'instant ma manière en
Armageddon et Ariane tari qui a battu
Ali resa en partie classique à Mérida
qui a fait qui a eu une
qui a pris une décision avec kayak très
très bizarre et qui a perdu la partie
après ça
et les classements vous avez sous les
yeux avec ma caméra
donc 7,5
et kookesh 14 et demi qui complète le
podium avec après 13 points on a amusé
qui vient de passer devant où est-ce les
sauts 12 et demi Magnus qui fait même
pas la moyenne à Magnus qui est vraiment
très difficile dans
Danse de dans cet événement media rock
qui fait 11 points à les résidents
9. et Ariane time qui fait 6
mais qui a quand même terminé le tournoi
en battant à l'irrédafir aux gens donc
tu es quand même une bonne note au final
pour ce tournoi pour Ryan taille qui
était le joueur local donc invité par
l'organisation
et puis écoute Fatou je crois que nous
et ben on a fini de commenter ce cet
événement pour cette année donc le
Norway de chaise 2023 il se termine une
grande tristesse un peu pour tout le
monde partout
de plus d'une semaine de commentaires
exactement on ne voit plus pas tout
j'étais voilà je t'avais enlever la
caméra désolé ça va être prêt et tu as
venu t'inquiète pas
et donc voilà
on sera amené à se revoir
plus tard
d'autres événements avec Fatou peut-être
en tout cas on vous tiendra au courant
je veux te remercier Patou de m'avoir
accompagné pendant toute cette semaine
pour les
chaises et puis remercier aussi
merci aussi tout le chat qui nous a
suivi pendant pendant ces 9 parties
remercier remercie aussi tous les les
gens sur YouTube sur twitch sur pièce 24
sur tous les sites qui ont pu regarder
etc on espère que les moments vous a plu
et oui du coup ben à la prochaine fois
on lit sur chelse 24 alors moi
j'avais déjà plein de trucs ouverts PC
rempli de tout mais je l'ai pas ouvert
mais la prochaine fois la série de
mettre à jour aussi là dessus avoir
quatre chats ouverts
et voilà et pas tout je te laisse si tu
veux le petit mot de la fin avant qu'on
coupe officiellement le stream
je te remercie également et merci
beaucoup au chat et à tous vos messages
bienveillants et à votre participation
et voilà ce fut un plaisir et un superbe
événement avec un superbe format et
merci Anna car notre reporter sur place
bien sûr
à tous bonne soirée bon week-end et je
vous dis à très bientôt ciao ciao